телеканалі та у середовищі масової
інформації Сьогодні ми з вами працюємо
на традиційній Серпневий педагогічний
науково-практичний конференції яка має
назву цього року Освіта освітяни
Незламні у війні
Я впевнений що для багатьох 24 лютого
цього року стало певним певною
неочікуваністю для не тільки для нас для
всієї країни і той виклик Який отримав
отримала освіта в Україні той виклик
який отримали освітяни Я впевнений що
кожен з вас сьогодні є одним з учасників
які вже
на шляху до перемоги Дякуємо всім
представникам хто сьогодні приєднався до
нашої конференції Дякую всім спікерам
хто знайшов сьогодні час будь ласка
прошу привітати один одного з початком
цієї конференції
[оплески]
шановні учасники хочу нагадати що перша
частина конференції - це пленарне
засідання Це близько 12 кейсів онлайн та
офлайн змішана форма навчання і хочу
звернути увагу що це Міжнародний статус
в нас буде дуже багато включень прямих
можливі технічні моменти тому будь ласка
Сподіваюсь на вашу підтримку та
Сподіваюсь на
нашу співпрацю та взаємодію але ж цей
момент вся конференція до нас важлива і
вона важлива не тільки для освітян вона
важлива це
державне значення сьогоднішньої нашої
зустрічі тому пані та панове якщо ви не
проти прошу за традицію
відкрити сьогоднішній
нашу зустріч нашу конференцію будь ласка
лунає їм України
Ще не вмерла України
слова
ні Бог
Дай нам браття
усміхнеться
доля
Згинуть наші
вороженьки як роса
на сонці
[музика]
запануємо
ми браття у
своїй Стороні
кожен за нашу свободу
браття козацького
нашу свого
чом козацького
[музика]
дякую
пані та панове ми розпочинаємо наші
репонарне засідання хочу нагадати тема
освіта освітяни Незламні у війні Наша
планета засідання поділяється на три
основних блоки це перший блок Ну він
логічний це виклики освіти в умовах
війни це виклики з якими ми які ми вже
прийшли пройшли Перепрошую і виклики які
нас очікують у новому навчальному році
наступний блок і також невеличкий анонс
- це моделі освітнього процесу
логічно які нас які вже є здобутки ми
послухаємо це буде такий невеличкий
інтенсив в нас буде три спікери і три
точки зору точки досвіду і третій блок
дуже важливий Також ви знаєте тим більше
конференція міжнародного статусу то це
співпраця Україна ЄС Ну а
починаю Починаємо ми наші плани
засідання це я думаю це і логічно і це
правильно це можливо традиційно тому
оновлювати форми та методи роботи
розвивати нові компетенції складних
умовах такі реалії освітян сьогодні
вашій увазі виступ міністра освіти і
науки України Сергія шкаррлика виклики в
умовах війни оновлення і розвиток Сергій
Миколайовичу будь ласка
[оплески]
Доброго ранку шановні українці Доброго
ранку шановні освітяни
в основі військової адміністрації пане
мерг все Віталій голова комітету Пані
Альона наш представник від батьків
Василь Григорович дорогі мої директори
департаментів керівників освіти
молодь партнери сьогодні
освіта освітяни точно Незламні війни у
війні оскільки якщо ми всі з вами
згадаємо як вона починалась як ми перший
день збирались вже 7 годин у нас було 7
годин ранку ми вже напрацювали з вами
певні кроки ми вже побігли побігли
швидко завдячуючи чому вже через 10 днів
співпраці освітян Верховної Ради
особисто голови комітету ми запустили
освітній процес оце є той крок який
сьогодні весь світ хоче знати як Це
відбувалось Як же це відбулося взагалі в
Україні який давали три дні
ми символічно сьогодні в Бучі символічно
треба їхати туди
де є приклад того як люди вистояли
гуманітарний штаб який тут був та
підтримка і та координаційна діяльність
керівників місцевих органів а сьогодні
тут Прекрасна школа сьогодні тут локація
ми стартуємо
безумовно освіта не стала виключенням і
освітянський фронт був чи не найважливий
найважливіший після ЗСУ
261 повністю зруйнований заклад освіти
2061 пошкоджений
багато чи мало 15%.
1300 закладів під окупацією
і ми на сьогодні вже говоримо
після нашої з вами майже піврічної
роботи що ми йдемо до 1 вересня
основними мобілізаційне завдання наше це
запуск освітнього процесу
Ми дякуємо Міністерство комітет всі
освітяни дякую батькам дякують учням
адже окрім тих що виїхали в нас
залишилося все ж таки майже 3 мільйони
600 дітей які навчалися були тобільовані
в Україні звісно за кордоном Трошки було
легше але це теж буде певним чином
організована
зустріч сьогодні міністра
Польщі освіти який яка мабуть на
сьогодні найбільше приймає наших дітей
в цілому жодної не табельованої дитини
347 тисяч дев'ятикласників 224 тисячі
одинадцятикласників отримали документи
про освіту з них ми
1153 документи щодо здобуття повної і 97
документів про здобуття базової освіти
видали через дипломатичні академії
дипломатичні установи за кордоном
співпраці з міністерством закордонних
справ
на жаль на жаль маємо втрати втрати
загиблих дітей але маємо і героїв
освітян які зі зброєю в руках дуже
потужно відстоювали горде Звання
освітянина і на фронті збройних сил
прошу
Вітаю вас всіх сердечно і щиро Шановні
колеги
щоб мені хотілось сказати напередодні
навчального року і вдень серпневої
конференції яка відбувається зовсім
незвичних і для освіти і для країни і
для всіх людей і для всього людства
мабуть умова я тут мені здається
усвідомив і зрозумів що
майбутнє це якраз то Чим я займаюся
останні 30 років за виключенням оцих
півроку це освіта Чому так Тому що
мабуть За освітою в майбутнє не мабуть а
напевне У нас є батьківщина яку треба
захищати яку треба любити і
який треба навчати
щоб вона була як я люблю казати і тут і
тут тобто і в серці і В розумі Чесно
кажучи я не розумію що ми тут робимо
якщо ми не будемо розпочинати навчальний
рік Мені би дуже хотілося щоб всі
учасники
навчального процесу освітнього процесу з
бажанням відносились до того що
відбувається в освіті не тільки в
загальній середній не тільки вищий не
тільки в позашкільній Представником якої
я є і серцем і душею
вболіваю за неї Мені би дуже хотілося
щоб всі ланки освіти запрацювали в
очному форматі але
на моє глибоке розуміння формат не
головне головне підходе головне якість і
Головне бажання всіх учасників
освітнього процесу брати в ньому участь
як показує останній час саме Від нашого
бажання і нашого переконання залежить
результат який ми хочемо досягти в
будь-якому процесі чи то війні чи то в
навчанні чи то у вихованні А загалом це
називається просто життя тому наша
країна має жити і має жити з освіченими
людьми з нашим майбутнім з нашими дітьми
саме тому ми маємо розпочати навчання
в будь-яких форматах але саме для дітей
і для майбутнього нашої країни Хай все
буде Україна
зараз у кожного свій фронт поки ми
захищаємо країну тут ваш фронт в місті
Києві і саме Від вас залежить яке
навчання буде з вересня з дітьми Я дуже
хочу щоб ви показали нашим дітям своїм
прикладом приклади інших людей яка у нас
чудова країна які люди живуть нашій
країні і задля чого взагалі ми боремося
на всіх цих фронтах
Я розумію що освітяни в нас такі люди
які можуть багато пережити і багато чого
зробити якщо всі і директори і вчителі
діти батьки об'єднаються То цей
навчальний рік буде
чудовий хочу в цей складний прямо
скажемо складний час побажати нам всім
наснаги Терпіння і витримки щоб подолати
ці всі ситуації різні які відбуваються в
нашій країні війна нікого не залишила
осторонь і всім зараз важко але я бажаю
щоб новий навчальний рік все ж таки
розпочався і На мою думку Головне щоб
він розпочався саме очно бо це дуже
важливо і одна із взагалі причин чому ми
тут воюємо щоб у наших дітей було все
гаразд дітям потрібно все ж таки не
дистанційна освіта Хоча вона себе теж
показала як такою ефективною і
ефективним інструментом але дітям
потрібно соціалізація дітям потрібно
бачити е-е погляд вчителя вчителю
потрібно відчувати дітей клас тому бажаю
щоб
наші збройних сил все вийшло так як ми
запланували і щоб у нас на більшості
території нашої країни вже з 1 вересня
була така змога і розпочалася саме Ось
на навчання
дякую
Отже ми 14 березня розпочали освітній
процес але освітній процес в собі
об'єднав не тільки Саме навчання цей
соціалізація це і психологічна підтримка
цей
евакуація дітей евакуація особливо дітей
з особливими освітніми потребами це
переміщення
не тільки освітян а взагалі українців на
безпечнішій території хтось
організовував поселення в приміщеннях в
тому числі і в закладах освіти
організацію побуду все інше
левову частку на це взяли саме освітяни
На жаль маємо 640 майже 641 тисячу учнів
які з першого по 11 клас які перебувають
за кордоном маємо майже 22,5 тисячі
вчителів а в Україні майже 80 тисяч
внутрішньо переміщених осіб я хочу
подякувати всім колегам хто розробляв
новітні механізми роботи в цих важких
умовах за два тижні перше мабуть з часів
Другої світової війни Ми розпочали
навчальний рік взагалі навчальний
семестр взагалі в незвичних для нас
умовах і тому групою керівників
департаментів освіти Міністерство освіти
народних депутатів з комітету Верховної
Ради було розроблено декілька варіантів
щодо організації освітнього процесу і в
основу цих варіантів були покладені саме
локація дітей дошці діти все-таки
знаходяться ось наші чотири моделі
учасники освітнього процесу знаходяться
або повернулися на території істотно
віддалені від зони бойових дій це одна
модель організації освітнього процесу
яку ми з вами організовували учасники
освітнього процесу є внутрішньо
переміщеними особами учасники освітнього
процесу перебувають в зоні проведення
бойових дій або на тимчасового
окупованих територіях над складна
категорія але ми також готові з ними
працювати і тимчасово знаходяться поза
межами України
хотів би просто декілька слів ми
сьогодні
запровадили кілька слів
озвучити кілька слів про Ці моделі наш
багаторічний партнер представник з
дитячого фонду ООН юнісеф в Україні
допоміг нам у наочнити цю інформацію
юнісепт взагалі
скрізь і всюди підтримує Україну і в
мирний шлях а особливо ця підтримка
стала досить такою вагомою і досить
взагалі відчутною під час війни вся
інформація яку ви бачите на слайді саме
саме і розроблялась разом з тим з
інсталяцією з підтримкою фахівців
юнісеф ми ви цю тематику всі ці моделі
отримали в роздаткового матеріалі не всі
моделі були унормовані
група освітян міжнародних партнерів
напрацювала народних депутатів
напрацьовувала зміни в існуючі документи
які сьогодні погоджуються з іншими
центральними органами виконавчої влади
ми вносимо зміни сьогодні Альона казала
там по 086 працівниці це зможемо
працювали працювали бак посіяли
санітарні особисто спілкувалась з усіма
тоді тут кожен мав підключатися з
міністерством охорони здоров'я я
абсолютно бачу що в нас вийде розпочати
розпочати Новий рік в умовах війни Я б
дуже хотів би звісно ми всі б хотіли щоб
цей новий навчальний рік був останній
який би починали під час війни
окрім нормативного поля нам ще довелося
працювати І над змістом особливо цього
року є перехід базової школи на новий
державний стандарт п'ятикласники мають
відчути цей перехід за навчаннями
продовженням реформи нової української
школи які вже розпочався в початкових
класах і на сьогодні ми не маємо права
зупинятись
результат нас підтримує Рада Європи нас
підтримує юнісеф нас підтримує Юнеско
нас підтримує організація об'єднаних
націй нас підтримують всі європейські
світові партнери діаспори конгресу
українців світу і сьогодні є вже
домовленість про друг підручників для
п'ятого класу з математики української
мови загальним накладом поле тонини 3
млн грн примірників на сьогодні секрет з
бюджету зробив нам Ну трошки незручності
на підручники Немає коштів але на
сьогодні ми плідно працюємо щоб такі
такі такі речі все-таки прибрати з
освітянського поля і сподіваюсь ми на
перше вересня суспільними зусиллями
вийдемо на концептуальну концептуальний
плюс
всі інші підручники в нас є доступні в
електронному qr-коді це майже 1300
примірників підручників і посібників які
сьогодні можуть бути використані окремо
хочу подякувати декількам видавництвам
ранок Генеза Оріон грамота і Літера за
підтримку і відновлення освіти вони
ухвалили рішення про перерахунок частини
прибутку від продажу комерційного
накладу підручників на рахунок Юнайтед
24 саме в контексті підтримки освіти
на допомогу учням батькам які
організують навчання за сімейною формою
вчителям створено кілька ресурсів і якщо
всеукраїнською школи онлайн яку ми
суттєво модернізували всі всі могли
ознайомитись раніше але під час ковіду
ми суттєво допрацювали і це був один з
таких порятунків під час під час війни
на сьогодні на локації у місті Львові в
Львівській політехніці буде відтворена і
проілюстрована дистанційна українська
школа які теж додатковий ресурс який нам
сьогодні суттєво покращують життя при
цьому нашими партнерами залишається
низка ціла низка приватних закладів
освіти які продовжують пропонувати
послуги інституційної освіти керівників
директорів я тут бачу низький уклін вам
за ту підтримку яка надавалась
безкоштовно в часи війни в першій
особливо перші тижні війни щедної
інновації цього року є переформатування
міжнародної української школи я сьогодні
До речі маю дуже гарний Дуже гарний
посил мені прийшло реєстрація по Литві
е-е Вона вже в реєстрі міжнародного
українського школа саме в Литві в
офіційному реєстрі з офіційним кодом ми
маємо сьогодні в міжнародній українській
школі 40 партнерських шкіл за кордоном
також міжнародна українська школа
курирує 10 українських хабіб за кордоном
там де залучені викладачі які на
сьогодні тимчасово знаходяться поза
межами України туди залучаються майже
550 тисяч українських дітей які
знаходяться за кордоном саме крутий ехаб
у нас в Варшаві який об'єднав навколо
себе ще 10 країн і з міністром освіти
Польщі який сьогодні буде виступати Я
вчора якраз таки говорив і дуже
подякував за таку гарну ініціативу
велика велика
увага в освітньому процесі має
приділятися не тільки Саме навчання
виховна робота
національно-патріотичне виховання
Катерина Володимирівна тут присутня як
заступник Міністра внутрішніх справ
якими почали Дякую вам за як партнеру
нашому з якими ми почали ще до війни
роботу по національного патріотичного
виховання по створенню класів безпеки
про поліцейському в школі по кнопці
безпеки по відеонагляду по всіх інших
безпекових складових і саме сьогодні
концепція національно-патріотичного
виховання спільно з МЗС з міністерством
внутрішніх справ з міністерством оборони
України затверджена і план заходів на її
виконання до 2025 року затверджений І я
хотів би закликати всіх ми не
цей національний патріотичне виховання є
обов'язковою складовою освітнього
процесу
і на виконання плану заходів з
національного патріотичного виховання
саме сьогодні запущено Сокіл Джура
Закарпатська область буде як на локації
представлена буде демонструвати 8 годин
ранку Діти вже побігли виконувати
завдання доручення змагатись між собою і
на локації наш Державний секретар він
теж приймав особисту участь з головою
військової адміністрації Закарпатської
ми говорили Я думаю що ми зможемо
подивитись на цей на цей процес
по черзі По черзі
[музика]
національно-патріотично виховання криза
Сокіл Джура та
в пропозиції
Я радий вітати всіх учасників гостів
Сьогодні ми перебуваємо на
Землі яка пролита пропитана кров'ю
молодих людей які захищали на той час
незалежність Карпатської України поки у
Джура відбувається напередодні шановні
організатори змагань шановні учасники
змагань шановні учасники національної
військово-патріотичної гри Джура шановні
друзі Шановні колеги від імені
Міністерства освіти і науки України від
імені міністра освіти і науки України
Сергія миколайовича-карлика від себе
особисто через себе Вітаю вас з початком
третього всеукраїнського завершального
етапу гри Джура приділяють значну увагу
військово-патріотичному вихованню молоді
адже колишній учасники гри Сокіл Джура
сьогодні стають в строю
лавах збройних сил України і мужньо
виконують я хочу сказати три важливих
слова була є і буде за те що підтримуєте
і Дякуємо за
[музика]
ваші організатори представники влади
Чернівецької області передаю вам символ
гри Джура
юні Джури я щиро вітаю Вас із цим для
нас радісним моментом
Закарпатська земля дуже рада прийняти
вас у себе
[оплески]
[музика]
бути людиною тричі
разом
така кількість молодих патріотів надихає
правда
з метою актуалізації національного
патріотичного виховання особливо під час
навалу російської агресії ми як
Міністерство пропонуємо розпочати
навчальний рік першим роком за тему ми
за темою Ми українці честь і слава
незламним всі рекомендації є просив би
долучитись всіх адже
знову ж таки не тільки освіта матеріали
навчальні ще і той дух незламності
українців і патріотизм до своєї землі
країни
не може обійти
е-е якось виступі своєму і диванних
експертів вони дуже гарно спостерігали
не тільки за збройними силами і за нами
яких тільки звинувачень нам не писали що
ми тільки не отримали як освітяни але
при цьому найкращу відповідь диванним
експертам дали наші діти
найбільше Ну майже 10 тисяч учасників
українського ммт випускники які під
кулями під бомбами під ракетами
готувалися до вступу отримали 200 балів
хоча б з одного предмету майже 3000
наших випускників отримали 200 балів з
кожного з трьох предметів давайте
поаплодуємо
[оплески]
Наші діти не тільки переконливо розвіяли
всі звинувачення діванних експертів а і
довели що Громадяни України мають
володіти українською мовою та знати
історію України при цьому незалежно від
того до якої з дисциплін Вони готувалися
ми пишаємось нашими дітьми дітьми вони
Їдь на майбутнє нашої держави
ми виклали більшу частину матеріалів як
ми діяли під час війни які методичні
рекомендації ми запроваджуємо в новий
навчальний рік і у вас кожного є
матеріали в яких є qr-код який ви можете
зайти на електронну сторінку
продемонструвати і взяти за основу в
собі в своїй роботі ті методичні
матеріали рекомендації
по завершенню по завершенню нашої
частини засідання розпочнеться робота по
12 локаціях на локаціях будуть
конкретизовані чітко питання
функціонування воєнного стану всіх всіх
секторів освіти дошкільна шкільна
позашкільна особливо професійно-технічна
фахове передвищує вища освіта питання
подальшого розвитку науки це все є ми я
пропоную продовжити потім роботу на
ключовій сьогодні в сьогоднішніх умовах
локації локації з безпеки Я дуже вдячний
знову ж таки міністерству внутрішніх
справ адже Катерина оленищене присутня і
ми ми вже декілька разів безпеки в
локації оглядали і досить символічно що
ми оглядаємо є Саме тут Де саме ця школа
була прихиском більше ніж майже на
400 наших українців які перебували в
самому от пеклі оточення І ця локація
витримала а сьогодні вона буде приймати
дітей
найголовніше завдання не загубити жодної
дитини в прямому і в переносному смислі
Кожна дитина має бути долучена до
освітнього процесу кажуть Кожна дитина
має перебувати в безпеці сьогодні не
лише важливо створити умови безпеки
сьогодні Важливо щоб батьки
повірили в те що освітня територія це
територія безпеки мені Наприклад дуже
багато запитань ставили як з одного так
і з іншого боку великі дослідження ідуть
освітній буцмент досліджує ми
досліджуємо служба якості освіти в нас
контекст контент охоплення аудиторій 290
тисяч батьків які ми яку ми обійшли
приблизно є є
чіткий результат стосовно цього але я
чув одну цікаву думку від батьків
Скажіть будь ласка я не впевнена що моя
дитина на сьомому або на восьмому
поверсі поки я на роботі більше і
безпеці ніж в школі адже є вчитель є
вихователь є закріплений працівник з
безпеки від ДСНС за кожній школі я
сьогодні я дуже вдячний Міністерство
внутрішніх справ за настільки кропітку
роботу в цьому контексті який точно
покаже де укриття які точно не кінець цю
дитину якій точно відповідальний за цю
дитину Отже наше завдання
не загубити жодної дитини де б
територіально вона не знаходилась із
метою саме популяризації безпеки з метою
повороття до навчання Міністерство
запускає сьогодні флешмоб повертаємось
до навчання заклад освіти територія
безпеки прошу на екран
[музика]
[оплески]
Дуже дякую всім
і ще як завжди скажу тримаймося
дякуємо
дякуємо за вашу доповідь і за чудовись
шановні Ну ви знаєте
старт флешмобу повертаюсь до навчання
тільки відбувся але як мені кажуть У нас
же є перші результати і перший колаж
будь ласка на екран до речі Прошу і вас
також приєднатися до цього флешмобу
сьогодні під час під час
Можливо пізніше можливо зараз хтось із
спікером сподобається і ви зробите свій
контент Отже якщо в нас будуть в нас
колаж з фотографії будуть пізніше Да
зараз да ну Давайте тоді можливо ми
маємо якось енергію запросити і нажати
мені ні просто увага найкраще
[музика]
і це приклад але це поле для Дякую за
оплески
[оплески]
кажуть це приклад А ви фантазуєте Я
вважаю що ми має бути прикладом і
демонструвати формати як це
використовувати адже кожен флешмоб - це
єднання кожен флешмоб - це об'єднання це
спільна взаємодія І до речі про єднання
до нас приєднався ми казали Сергій
сказав про у юнісеф яку важливу роль
відіграє юсеф і ми бачили проект спільно
і спільно до навчання вже з'явився
меседж я бачу пані та панове будь ласка
Я запрошую до нашої Президії голову
представництв в Україні Мурат Шахін ваше
оплески
пане Мурат приєднується до нас але його
кейс Later Окей трошки пізніше
[музика]
можемо про це сказати Окей Мурат йокейс
лейтру рокитнів також хочу нагадати
бачите зараз наші вимушеновний спікер в
гарнітурах для перекладу з синхронного
будьте уважними якось так підготуйте бо
через один два кейси в нас можливо
включення і будь ласка бути готові до
щоб технічно сприйняти онлайн трансляцію
ми знову ж таки продовжуємо продовжуємо
щеплення засідання і ми з вами говорили
про співпрацю про взаємодію і як важливо
коли
Міністерство ефективно і швидко
співпрацює з комітетом тому пані та
панове Верховна Рада України як головний
законодавчий орган держави разом з
фаховими комітетами
дозволяє відповідні проєкти які мають
позитивно вплинути на впровадження
інновації в сфері освіти і науки тому
Запрошуємо до виступу голову комітету
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти
науки та інновації Сергія бабака будь
ласка
[оплески]
[музика]
Доброго дня шановні друзі Шановні колеги
вже майже 6 місяців як країна потерпає
він Великого вторгнення від війни як
сказав Сергій Миколайович більше ніж 2
300 закладів освіти пошкоджено майже 300
з них зруйновано більше ніж тисячі дітей
постраждало на жаль більше ніж 360 з них
загинуло в цій війні і ці втрати На жаль
продовжуються більше ніж 600 тисяч дітей
знаходиться зараз за кордоном шкільного
віку і близько 20 тисяч вчителів це
величезний виклик для системи це
величезний виклик для кожного з нас це
насправді трагічно і ці На жаль
негативні явища в країні поки що
продовжуються І все Це звісно вимагає
швидкої реакції і від влади взагалі Від
міністерства від Верховної Ради від
офісу президента
І знаєте мені здається хтось в
Стародавньому Римі колись сказав що коли
гучно працюють гармати закони не
працюють
бо так сталося що під час війни якраз
загальноприйняті норми і закони
пристають працювати І з цим ми
категорично не погоджуємось і тому з
першого дня війни ми знаходимось на
постійному контакті із міністром освіти
і з офісом президента і робимо все для
того щоб гнучку реагувати на ті виклики
які перед нами всіма стоять За останні
півроку ми прийняли тільки нашим
комітетом 10 законів які зробили всім
нам і системі дали можливість не просто
вистояти а й продовжувати розвиватися ви
пам'ятаєте перший закон про державні
гарантії для здобувачів освіти для всіх
вчителів для всіх працівників для всіх
освітян які забезпечували виплати
заробітних плат і стипендії продовження
функціонування системи освіти на
дистанційному форматі і звільнення або
відстрочка від мобілізації для всіх нас
хто працює в системі освіти бо це
насправді важливо Хоча багато з нас самі
добровільно пішли на сест комітету своїм
збройні сили і досі захищають нашу
країну і велика шана і подяка їм за це
ми дуже швидко реагуємо на всі виклики
які є
зробили іншу вступну кампанію цього року
розуміючи що напередодні на самому
початку війни що зовнішнє незалежне
оцінювання в тому вигляді в якому ми всі
звикли до нього на жаль неможливо і за
цей короткий проміжок часу все ж таки
підготували національний
мультиппредметний тест який продовжує
навіть в умовах війни забезпечувати
рівні можливості для здобуття освіти і
таких змін насправді багато але зміни
мають бути не тільки як реакція на
зовнішні виклики або подразнення Ми
також намагаємося робити зміни які нам
наперед дадуть ще й можливості розвивати
систему незважаючи на ті обставини в
яких ми з вами всі знаходимось тому один
з останніх законів був так званий закон
Про іком який заклав величезний
фундамент взагалі до цифровізації але не
просто для
цифровізації як такої а для того щоб в
першу чергу з вчителів з адміністраторів
освітян зняти паперове навантаження і це
основна мета яку ми намагаємося цим
законом власне закласти ми І звісно
викликів у нас з вами цей навчальний рік
буде більше ніж завжди ми вже останні
два роки звикли до важкого виклику
такого як ковід налагодили дистанційну
освіту змішане навчання зараз буде важче
або грошей в країні буде менше Але разом
з тими все одно намагатимемось робити
все за що залежить від нас від кабінету
міністрів взагалі від влади для того щоб
розблокувати деякі речі вчора в нас було
масштабне засідання комітету і багато з
вас там до речі були присутніми В яке
стосувалося підготовки до початку
навчального року і на одна з один з
елементів за які Ми домовились з
міністерством фінансів це наприклад
розблокування 590 умови для того щоб
могли закупити шкільні автобуси
ми будемо продовжувати над цим працювати
Це лише перший крок але це тим який буде
швидко зроблено ви всі знаєте що в нас
на балансі у місцевої влади майже 7
тисяч автобусів було до війни Зараз ми
втратили більше ніж 3000 з них частина
знищена частина пошкоджена частина пішла
на потреби збройних сил ми все розуміємо
як освітяни і першими і постав
підставили своє плече допомоги збройним
силам і в переміщенні внутрішнього
приміщеним особам Але разом з тим ми
розуміємо що все одно процес не повинен
зупинятися дітей треба підвозити
особливо з тих кіл які зруйновані або
пошкоджені і там неможливо відновити
освітній процес Тому це перший крок а
наступним кроком Ми домовились мінфіном
що ми все ж таки спробуємо розблокувати
залишки освітньої субвенції які
знаходяться в регіонах для того щоб ви
їх могли без обмежень використовувати на
всі освітні потреби Які у вас є на даний
час я сподіваюсь що Таким чином ми всі
зможемо виконати побажання наших освітян
які зараз знаходяться на фронті яких ми
сьогодні чули
які всі просять нас як і ми просимо вас
давайте все ж таки спробуємо З 1 вересня
максимально відновити процес навчання
офлайн це дуже важливо тому що ми мусимо
Незважаючи на всі обставини
продемонструвати вже мільйонний разом За
останні півроку в цьому світу що Україна
не зламана що освіта Незламна що
освітяни не зла і наші діти назвали і ми
будемо кожного дня працювати і Працюємо
з першого дня війни кожен на своєму
фронті кожен на своєму місці Але в нас
свої задачі ми працюємо Діти повинні
навчатись тому що це власне забезпечить
не тільки їх власним майбутнє а й
майбутні всієї нашої країни тому Шановні
колеги я в кожному з вас і всім нам
бажаю успішного нового навчального року
і найголовніше спокійно нового
навчального року Дякую Дякуємо Сергію
якби повертаємось до навчання так також
пані та панове будь ласка технічне
приготувались якщо це можливо
приготуйтесь в нас на зв'язку Міністр
освіти і науки Польщі
щемисла в чарник будь ласка
вітаємо вас як нас чути
давайте зв'язок перевіримо
[музика]
нас добре чути так так так все можемо
вас чекають чекають на вашу вітання на
ваш кейс на вашу думку будь ласка
[музика]
медикації на Україні і Просто якщо можна
ми будемо починати Дуже дякуємо всім вам
за можливість участі та поміняти кілька
слів обміну досвіду про освіту в Україні
та Польщі жінку я застали контакт
міністра скарлатам і за а Дем'яна
зданіться мужчина робить вона більше все
ж важче жінку і роблять Вчора йшов
розмови надавати на стаціонарний і
здавної на Україні
за постійну співпрацю і контакт за обмін
поглядами на тему того що ми робимо І що
ще маємо зробити а також Про вчорашню
розмову про стаціонарну стаціонарне
навчання
стаціонарний здалена бо то єсть зверху
уважно з пункту університет в сума якого
осьмився Тищенко
джетті українських інтереса
стаціонарну та дистанційне навчання тому
що це дуже важливо з точки зору тих
800-700 тисяч дітей які навчаються з
України в Польщі Все повинні вже
досконалі розуміє дощівки Міністерства
української майств аби там где-то цинком
можна
брати стаціонарного Я хочу сказати що я
розумію ваше старання повернути де це
тільки можливо стаціонарне навчання
[музика]
містах України фірм міста України
можлива розгляна А то ж Вінник мій сад
Анджеліни лідочшення
але також розуміємо що в багатьох місцях
України Це неможливо зважаючи на цю
брутальну війну але також з з страхом
батьків так чи інакше і все скидощів і в
цьому кіровом треба чи сама абсолютно
знання і має в наших партія так чи
інакше всі зусилля які ви направляєте у
цьому напрямку заслуговують на нашу
підтримку і пошалу
ось тут близько серед
Ми так і чини може в ній е-е в Самборі
вбили він час просто двічі нації з
польським системним шляхом в Польщі з
тих 800 тисяч дітей які були знаходилися
у Польщі близько 200 000 вже записані в
польську систему освіти рід
участь нічого гнався здалений з Україною
тому Ми рахуємо що решта 300 тисяч дітей
які перебувають у Польщі Записані на
дистанційну систему навчання з України і
все ж моторчик Як є додавання інакше
інші українські
ми відкриті також на них а також ми
готові прийнятись слідуючих дітей які
будуть покидати Україну приїжджати до
Польщі але все раз є що з вілком
покращують так само віруем завше в
розмові з паном міністром але я хочу ще
раз сильно підкреслити те про що я
завжди говорив в розмові з паном
міністром нині є стежка також шайба вас
начнем з того щоби за опікова чи ні
війна там час скидали мушу аби Спас це
бо є ми ж сам а неполчене Волині
подлягли в Україні Ми не для того щоб
забрати ваших дітей ми для того щоб
піклуватися на них тоді коли вони
потребують своєї допомоги але ми
розуміємо що вони мають повернутися до
вільної незалежної України Це ж там і
патріотиз зі звернення доки і тут все
погратися
з України їх патріотизм дуже глибокий і
тут я з цим хотів привітати всіх
освітдовців вчителів з України
двічі українських польським системи
то дуже 200 тисяч дітей польській
системі освіти тільки з 24 лютого це
багато але ні на твоє не жаданах жадних
проблем виховавших Ані жадних проблем в
контактах про мінсопроискому Але ми не
спостерігали жодних і я підкреслюю
жодних проблем з вихованням чи
контактами між молоддю з Польщі та
Україною той особливі ще заслуга
обустролена за рук на польських жіночих
там але так що цих діячів української
хто вже стали викладання іде докладати
щоб з України це звичайно заслуга обох
сторін і польських вчителів але також
вчителів українських які виховали молодь
Таким чином
тому я вас дуже з цим вітаю І дуже вам
дякую і все ж ми як пам'ятаєте
[оплески]
з Україною
яка є ситуація на Україні на біжансу і
омоніторингу внеш на нашій родині
міністрів так як я вже казав ми готові
прийняти слідуючих дітей з України ми
знаємо як виглядає ситуація в Україні ми
її постійно спостерігаємо на нашій раді
Міністрів
адвокації українських діячів польських
школах ми постійному зв'язку з
самоврядуванняльниками ми передаємо їм
сотні мільйонів злотих на і це кошти на
освіту дітей з України Так нам
маркінечно тільки потім
до НАТО Чи наші колеги з Європейським
дали нам бракувач Нам належить шротській
так жодна адвокація чи те що поїдемо по
розум до голови в консул помышляв
солідарності з уходцем із України
також хотів додати що ми будемо це
робити далі незважаючи на поведінку
наших колег з заходу які не видають нам
належних нам коштів і ми надіємося що
вони все-таки
зрозуміють як треба поводитися солідарно
відносно біженців з України
[музика]
пріоритета вільно незалежна Україна та
майбутнє українців є для нас сьогодні
абсолютним пріоритетом а також почався
українських студентів на польських очах
которые
діаграмах наба то і народу
мільйони звати тому також тисячі
студентів з України отримують допомогу в
рамах програми нава національної
Агентство з питань академічних обмінів
адже ми там щось сказали ваші значення
до своїх домов ми будемо продовжувати це
діяти маючи надію що війна в Україні
швидко закінчиться і всі зможуть
повернутися до своїх домівок».»
Дуже дякую за всі зусилля українських
вчителів
Дякуємо вам пане сумислав Дякуємо за те
як ви і вся весь польський народ
підтримує що страшного скажемо вам
підтримує і безпеку та освіту нашого
майбутнього наших дітей та всіх родин
хто наразі в евакуації дуже вам дякую
Від всієї України
[оплески]
Дякую вам дякую
ми жили ми будували ми виховували та
навчали дітей були щасливими
поки не прийшла війна
але ми сильні
[музика]
ми відбудовуємо і відновлюємо
Ми створюємо безпечні умови для наших
дітей та громадян
[музика]
переможемо
[оплески]
Дякуємо Ми продовжуємо нашебленерне
засідання освіта освітяни Незламні у
війні нагадую і буду нагадувати Ми е-е
повертаємось до навчання всі разом
з кожним кейсом який сьогодні чуємо від
наших спікерів
ми зараз говоримо далі не тільки про
співпрацю ви бачите Зараз ми вже
відокремили момент виклику
по локаціям Да По є діти які знаходяться
в евакуації є діти які знаходяться
в різних територіальних площинах скажемо
так і ми казали що школа - це територія
безпеки так а ми трошки меседж цей зараз
розширюємо та локалізуємо по наступний
кейс - це освіта Київщини територія
безпеки і ми зараз поговоримо про
неймовірну роботу по відновленню
інфраструктури області зокрема
підготовки обласних закладів
до навчального року здійснює Київська
військово- обласна адміністрація завдяки
зусиллям злагодженої команди обласної
адміністрації Сьогодні ми впевнено
можемо казати Київщину територія безпеки
запрошую до виступу голову Київської
обласної військової адміністрації
Олексія Кулеба будь ласка
[оплески]
дякую
Шановний Сергій Миколайович вона
колеги Шановні освітяни дуже радий вас
вітати на Київщині
це місце Воно дуже символічне ми про це
будемо казати сьогодні не один раз тому
що 6 місяців тому назад в березні тут
відбувалися зовсім інші події
ми будемо завжди про це пам'ятати це те
що ми ніколи не забудемо
але завдяки збройним силам України
завдяки нам з вами
у кожного був свій фронт ми відбили
ворога з Київщини
і сьогодні вже в серпні ми проводимо тут
конференцію надзвичайно важливо
конференцію яка дасть змогу всім нашим
дітям нашому майбутньому нормально Жити
вчитися і рухатись вперед
Я хочу сказати що зараз багато йде
розмов про те що люди які залишились
вони не герої вони просто виконували
свій обов'язок
Я з дитинства чую про освітян про
працівників поліції про всіх хто працює
бюджетній сфері що вони просто виконують
свій обов'язок
я хочу подякувати кожному
починаючи від директора школи технічного
працівника за те що вони просто
залишились на своєму робочому місці і
виконували свій обов'язок
ми його виконуємо Завжди коли йде дощ
коли йде сніг коли в нас з'являються у
світі виклики на рівні ковіда 19
а також на жаль випала доля вам
виконувати свій обов'язок і під час
війни всі люди які виконують просто свій
обов'язок під час війни вони справжні
герої як можна обійти
75 наших звичайних водіїв шкільних
автобусів
які вивозили
під час евакуації людей не тільки з
Київської області
вони це робили за покликом серця
їх ніхто не примушував
це був просто їх обов'язок
їх всіх відзначили державними нагородами
ми заплатили велику ціну
за те що ворога тут немає
нас зруйнована інфраструктура
215 закладів освіти зруйновано в тій чи
інші
стадії в нас повністю зруйновано 5 шкіл
великих шкіл які
надавали свої послуги тисячам дітей
нас повністю зруйновано шість дитячих
садочків
але ми це все відбудуємо ми це вже
робимо в нас є чудові партнери наші
іноземні колеги
в нас є держава в нас є уряд в нас є
народні депутати і ми зараз не
відокремлюємо один від одного
я хочу подякувати кожному тому що зараз
всі роблять спільну роботу і спільний
результат
те що нам ніколи не вдасться повернути
це життя 38 наших дітей які загинули в
Київській області
1445 цивільних осіб на жаль ця цифра не
остаточно які загинули в Київській
області
наш обов'язок Пам'ятати про це і наш
обов'язок завжди про це говорити
Ми не маємо про це забувати
тим не менш
дуже важлива і правильне рішення про
відновлення навчального року для нас для
Київщини воно Зрозуміло Як для іншої
області
в червні місяці в Київській області
почали працювати дитячі садочки хочу
подякувати за це і міністру і всім людям
які до цього причетні
це велика справа для наших дітей для
наших батьків
на сьогоднішній день ми виконуємо
завдання які поклали перед нами в нас
1353 заклади освіти Ми в комунальних
закладах на 100% вже провели перевірку
разом з робітниками
ДСНС поліції ми розуміємо недоліки Які в
нас є ми знаємо про ті об’єкти які в нас
зруйновані знаємо про ті об’єкти які на
жаль не обладнані безпечними укриттями
Але зрозуміло що ми зробимо все для того
щоб діти не залишились без нагово
навчального року
ми будемо використовувати підвози ми
будемо оптимізовувати наші навчальні
заклади це обов'язково для нас дуже
важливо рішення про відновлення
590 постанови внесення змін наш
автобусний флот На жаль був зруйнований
більш ніж на третину під час війни і
зараз це нам дасть можливість його
поповнювати Таким чином знову ж таки
надавати послугу дітям і батькам щодо
підвозу їх до нових шкіл
Я хочу ще раз сказати що
відновлення нового навчального року в
таких областях як Київська область це
поштовх нового життя відновлення нової
Київщини Да ми будемо жити в Нових
реаліях Да ми не захищені від загрози
терористичної
армії Росії але відповідальність ми
розуміємо і ми готові зробити все для
того щоб навчальний рік в на Київщині
розпочався 1 вересня так як завжди Дякую
кожному з вас Дякую за роботу Слава
Україні
Дякуємо пане Олексій також Ми
продовжуємо говорити про Київщину і
символізм місця де ми сьогодні проводимо
серпневу конференцію міжнародну
сохневого конференцію ми зараз обучі І
це місто герой це місто приклад це місто
мотиватор який надав всій Україні
приклад як відстоювати так все правильно
сказали
людські життя не повернути але цей
приклад зараз в кожному з нас в кожному
українці тому ми всі пам'ятаємо що
відбулося обуче але ж Ми віримо і вже
відновлення і в мене такий цікавий текст
наче легендарний птах Фенікс відродив
відродився з пепол з попелу так і Буча
як і сотні міст мають відродитися і ми
вам в цьому Будемо допомагати Запрошуємо
до виступу бучанського міського голову
Анатолію федорука будь ласка
[оплески]
Доброго дня шановні пані та панове
учасники форуму Шановний пане міністри
пане голову Київської військової
адміністрації
знаєте попри виклики хвилювання
щоденного турботу яку ми маємо з вами
сама думка проведення серпневої
конференції освітянської та й думка про
1 вересня початок навчального року
вселяє впевненість в тому що спільну і
збройними силами України обов'язково
переможемо в цій несправедливо
розв'язанні по відношенню до України
війни російською Федерації але
переможемо і як нація і як народ і
все-таки маючи цей історичний виклик ми
його гідно пройдемо і один із етапів
якраз є той який ми сьогодні і
обговорюємо і приймаємо участь що з 1
вересня в різному форматі виходячи із
умов які були запроваджені законодавцем
освітні заклади по всій території
України де це безпечно де це можливо
будуть відбуватися і мені звичайно
приємно що
Київщина якщойно
Олексій Володимирович зазначив Бучанська
громада яка була повністю окупована і
звільнена нашим нашими збройними силами
розпочинає в когорті освітян України
новий навчальний рік і в технічному
плані ми якщойно мали фактично експертну
дискусію перед початком форуму
констатуємо що за короткий відлік часу
освітянський заклади дошкільна освіта
школи вищі навчальні заклади які
розташовані на території міста будуть
підготовлені належним чином в тому числі
в питаннях безпеки
але користуючись нагодою що І це не
випадково як пан міністр зазначив місце
проведення було цієї серпневої
конференції обрано місто Буча місто
герой місто яке
зазнало напевно найбільших втрат
людських жертв
невинно закатованих російськими
окупантами терористами фактично
цивільні громадяни тож не таку ми
впізнаваність і ви бачите такого славу
навіть хотіли мати ми хотіли щоб нами
пишалися здобутках в економічних
гуманітарних в інших Ну точно не те що
нам довелося пережити пережити
громадянам мого міста але напевно
Господь дає виклики сильним
тим які здатний спроможні це витримати
винести І дійсно якщойно було анонсовано
відродитися із пепла для того щоби
показувати і демонструвати всьому світу
що ми дійсно сильна нація і здатна
тримати цей виклик який тримають наші
збройні сили і Всеукраїнське суспільство
тож за короткий місячний період окупації
на превеликий жаль Ми вимушені
констатувати що майже 3000 об'єктів
російської окупаційні війська
зруйнували
ступінь ушкодження різна Ми
констатуємо що з першого дня військової
агресії і з 14-ти населених пунктів які
входять до нас в адміністративне
підпорядкування в результаті реформи
практично майже всі а з 3 березня всі
були
дуже великий жаль
окупованими велика кількість
руйнувань об'єктів
різнопланового характеру від житлових
будинків доведення бізнесу були
ушкодження або зруйновані вщент що
сьогодні дійсно великим тягарем іношую
лягає як на виконання бюджету так і на
виконання тих програм і тих завдань які
стоять перед нами як перед місцевою
владою із
53-тисячного міста в період окупації
залишалося виконуючи ті завдання і той
функціонал всього 3,5 якщо бути
коректним 3700 громадян мешканців міста
А є населені пункти такі як Бабинці
здвижив калублянка ті що північніше від
Бучі північніше в сторону Білорусії які
з першого дня були 100% окуповані і я
користу з нагодою коли слухав і виступ А
на міністра і виступ пана голови
згадував завідуючих садочків чи
завгоспів як ми їх називаємо по
технічній частині шкіл Які фактично
тілом і грудью боронили свій заклад Не
даючи російським окупантам нищити
грабувати ці заклади і це дійсно
виконання своїх обов'язків але це
героїчні вчинки і ми цих громадян маємо
пам'ятати цінувати І шанувати
обов'язково це будемо робити і робимо на
превеликий жаль як мною було вже
зазначено
419 громадян мого міста а сумарно по
громаді це цифра значно більша 462
мирних цивільних громадян в тому числі
педагоги лікарі Люди різного віку 9
дітей
російськими окупаційними військами були
вбиті і закатовані
Так так саме закатовані І це
характеризує так званий той русский мир
який вони сповідують і несуть
всьому світу про пропаганду ведуть його
це вбивства насильство і грабіжи і ми це
маємо пам'ятати і доносити цю інформацію
Дайте будь ласка наступний слайд
на превеликий жаль і
заклади освіти дошкільної освіти також
зазнали значної руйнації грабежу Як я
говорив І ми готуючись до
чергового приємного але виклику до 1
вересня до початку навчального року
максимально комунікації із обласною
військовою адміністрацією з профільним
міністерством з урядом з фондами
міжнародними фондами які діють в Україні
з нашими партнерами взаємодіями для того
щоб цей іспит перед своїми громадянами
перед дітьми педагогами здати на відміну
і я думаю що ми попри ті виклики
справимося З цим завданням
тож Олег Іванович як начальник відділу
освіту у нас щоденну турбується не лише
за проведення конференції а й за
ремонтні роботи він освоює в нову
професію Дайте будь ласка наступний
слайд
маючи таку ступінь руйнації ми відразу
ставили собі за мету облікувати
зафіксувати дати відповідь громадянам що
з їхнім помешканням а саме головне
зафіксувати кожен злочин який був
зроблений росіянами
але це не самоціль це обов'язок довести
цю справу до логічного завершення щоб
військовий трибунал був на злочинцями А
що стосується відновлення і повернення
громадян ми розробили спільну із
державної програмою і місцеву програму
Вдома краще аби повернути громадян нашої
територіальної громади разом з їхніми
дітьми до своїх помешкань зробити Це
можна лише
даючи відповіді на ті виклики де без
безпечно де є помешкання де є соціальні
послуги і тому подібне тож ті етапи ми
успішно теж відносно виходячи з умов
проходимо проводимо
роботу Продовжуйте будь ласка слайді
наступне ми підрахували збитки
відповідно як
по тій методиці яку уряд запропонував
так і міжнародний організації проводять
теж аналіз цих збитків і ця цифра
вражаюча майже мільярд
доларів нанесені збитків всі
об'єктам різної форми власності на
території нашої громади досить успішно
спільно з урядом України і Польщі Ми
вирішили питання тимчасових містечок
модульних містечок для Ну як внутрішньо
переміщених так і громадян нашої нашого
міста які потребують який втратили житло
і тут різнопланові програми у нас ідуть
як модульні місця так і розміщення в
санаторно-курортній зоні селища Ворзель
яке входить адміністративно до нашої
громади Ми також плануємо розміщати там
цей громадян варто зазначи розумію що
розпочинається
завдяки обласній програмі будівництва
індивідуального житла і покупка квартир
для людей які втратили помешкання і це
розв'язує ту проблему яка існує у нас на
сьогодні
наступний слайдів що стосується
користуючись тим що це все-таки
Серпневий освітній заклад більше уваги
хочу приділити якраз освітній тематиці в
нашій громаді до 24 лютого ми будували
школи садочки розвивали мережу бо в тому
наші регіон потребував фактично нових
закладів і це приміщення в якому ми
знаходимося з вами воно рік тому назад
було здано в експлуатацію по програмі
президента велике будівництво Ми
отримали цей прекрасний заклад але поруч
з ним в нашій громаді будується ще дві
загальноосвітні школи і два дошкільних
навчальних заклади я про них дещо буду
говорити звертаючись і до народних
депутатів і до профільного Міністерства
тому що тому що пояснив пізніше
чуть-чуть Ми ремонтуємо покрівлі
ремонтуємо вікна ремонтуємо самі будівлі
тому що ступінь руйнації є досить
високий 75% і вище там приймаємо
управлінські рішення що на тому місці
уже і не варто відбудовувати а робити
сучасний комплекси тобто все це в
процесі
саме головне кожен заклад який
функціонує на території громади має бути
оснащений до 1 вересня він буде
оснащений безпековими нормами для того
щоб і педагоги а саме головне Діти і
їхні батьки були впевнені що відвідуючи
той чи інший освітній заклад
надзвичайної громаді
вони захищені і по всім стандартам
нормам ми забезпечимо щодо 1 вересня це
саме так відбулося
успішність реалізації наскільки це можна
говорити в наших умовах успішність
відбувається завдяки і державним
програмам обласним міжнародним Але в
тому числі і
міжмуніципальне співробітництво із
партнерами з містами і партнерами ми і
до вторгнення Російської Федерації
досить потужно працювали з міжнародними
нашими і фондами і колегами і містами і
партнерами які з першого дня фактично
прийшли на допомогу і взяли на себе
ступінь відповідальності за той стан
речей і вихід з нього
про який ми з вами і говоримо що всі
заклади мають бути до 1 вересня
відремонтовані обладнані Я з вашого
дозволу не буду перераховувати тому що
перелік великий але сьогодні буде теж
знакова унікальна можливість
підписання угоди про початок будівництва
нової загальноосвітньої школи із
дошкільним закладом в Ново мікрорайоні
це мова не йде про ремонт про
відновлення зруйновано це про нове
будівництво із Литовським бізнесом пан
айверас є тут і я користуючись нагодою
просив би в подальшому це е-е зробити цю
дію тому що це нам надто важливо
взагалі в планах на поточний рік
розпочати і по інших програмах
міжнародним які діють будівництво і
першої школи і нового навчального
закладу Але разом з тим Я хочу звернути
увагу що в нас є об'єкти які ми
розпочинали в минулому році і
логічно мали завершити в поточному але
якраз 590 постанова не дає нам
можливість це здійснити до фінансувати а
це два дошкільних навчальних заклади
синяківському старостаті і в місті Буча
по вулиці Лесі Українки ось ви бачите їх
на екрані
ступінь їхньої готовності
85.95 відсотків Тобто ми можемо фактично
Провівши певні управлінські рішення
давши дозвіл на фінансування до
фінансування вже до поточного
навчального року їх відкрити тож Шановні
колеги Шановні учасники форуму Я
безмежно вдячний організаторам за те що
саме місце проведення такого заходу
такого форуму обраного
знакове місто Буча тому що саме звідси
ми маємо продемонструвати що ті кроки
які роблять і уряд і Верховна Рада
виконавча гілка влади і народу України
вселяють впевненість твердо впевненість
в тому що ми обов'язково переможемо тож
перемога Буде за нами і слава Україні
[оплески]
Дякуємо вам пане Анатолій Ну і я
перепрошую в нас зараз такий досвід Ми
всі з вами отримаємо прямо зараз ми
побачимо на власні очі е-е як
відбувається оце Відродження тому що
будь ласка в нас вже все підготовлено Я
запрошую до підписання меморандуму щодо
співпраці з проектування та залучення
коштів на нове будівництво закладу
загальної середньої освіти та
дошкільного закладу з представником
проекту вікі-інвест та бейтп Литва пан
айверас королівський будь ласка та
мир
бучанський міський голова Анатолій
Федорук будь ласка
По протоколу нагадую треба подивитись на
аркуш паперу взяти
так дуже гарний і можливо разом нагадую
після того як в нас з'являється підпис
ми посміхаємось один одному і на камеру
так так так так так так це служба
протоколу розумієте ми тут так
пані та панове
меморандум оголошується підписаним
логотипом Бучача стоп Перепрошую
якщо вони проти годин
меморандум Візьміть будь ласка так о
дивіться ось так о все буде Перепрошую
Це такий
[оплески]
але я з вашого дозволу хочу виконати
певну дві почесних місії
[музика]
вручити йому таку сувенірну пам'ятну річ
виготовили наші умільці виготовили такі
пам'ятні знаки будь ласка на сьогодні на
пам'ять про сьогоднішню подію це
фактично закладка тієї капсули лише в
таких умовах початку будівництва школи
то сподіваюся що ми технічно все
організуємо належним чином щоби уже
Восени в вересні розпочати будівництво
освітнього закладу
[оплески]
Я думаю що вся прогресивна Людина мусить
сейчас обязательно обов'язково потримати
Україну вас всіх яка нам може так ми
робить наша компанія
відчуємо Україну що ми переможем всё
звать носить Дякую вам всім
[оплески]
Дякую І в нас не вибачаються з
української мови ми вам Дякуємо за те що
ви говорите українською Анатолій і
меморандум вашого Оплески Ми продовжуємо
так
[оплески]
Ну що міжнародність підтверджена
максимально Як настрій у нас якщо супер
супер супер бачите Оплески 30% посмішок
60%.»
[музика]
[оплески]
Олексію Володимир чи Шановні колеги
друзі
Я хотів би в рамках теми яка заявлена і
в зв'язку з таким невеликим регламентом
зупинитись лише на окремих напрямах
дослідницькі підтримки академії освіти в
цей час перше дошкільна освіта на жаль
війна не дала нам змоги створити
інститут раннього розвитку дитини та
дошкільної освіти але центр з такою
назвою який функціонує в інституті
проблем виховання за цей час створив
освітню платформу пташки для України
освіти і піклування за період бойових
дій на ній зареєструвались понад 21
тисяча електронних кабінетів з яких 28%
- це родин і дітей з сімей українських
біженців надано системну
психолого-педагогічного конструктивну
допомогу дітям та родинам і зокрема в
Київській області
проведено всеукраїнський
інтернет-конференції освітній процес в
закладах дошкільної освіти в умовах
воєнного стану 6,5 тисяч учасників і
реалізовано іншим цікаві напрямки друге
модернізація змісту загальної середньої
освіти міністр говорив що цього
навчального року
п'ятий клас школи переходить до нових
програм до нового стандарту вчені
академії підготували підручники з усіх
предметів для п'ятого класу що дуже
важливо зміст цих
підручників взаємозгоджений усіма
авторськими колективами і ми дуже раді
тішимося і дуже вдячні щоб більшість
учителів України обрали саме підручники
академії Ми продовжуємо цю роботу з тим
щоб з шостої і наступні класи також були
забезпеченими якісними академічними
підручниками з усіх предметів
до уваги всіх колег 25 серпня в онлайн
режимі відбудеться традиційна Серпнева
вебка конференція вчені напевно України
українському вчителями де освітяни
будуть мати можливість безпосередньо від
авторів підручників почути коментарі і
методичні поради посилання на
веб-конференцію можна зайти на сайті
напрям України третє цифровізація освіти
з метою наукового впливу на процеси
цифровізації в академії сторони інститут
синхронізації освіти інститут заснував
потужну електронну бібліотеку яка
містить праці всі праці практично вчених
академії і нею користуються
вчені і педагоги із 182 країн світу
інститут також має один з найкращих
електронних наукових журналів
інформаційної технології засобів
навчання його читають фахівці з 196
країн світу
і ця установа працює над інноваційною
електронною енциклопедією освіти
електронної енциклопедія освіти широкого
наукового резонансу набули розробки
вчених цього інституту з питань
застосування хмарних технологіях
технологій у закладах освіти
впровадження методичної системи
використання електронних освітніх
ресурсів нагальним завданням Яке зараз
реалізує інститут є створення для
вчителів відкритої системи підвищення
цифрової кваліфікації четверте
національне патріотичне виховання
вченими інституту проблеми виховання
оновленого парціальну програму
національно-патріотичного виховання
дітей дошкільного віку Україна має
батьківщина моя Батьківщина який надана
гриф Міністерство освіти науки України
підготовлено Методичні рекомендації з
військово-патріотичного виховання учнів
навчально-методичні посібник
військово-патріотичне виховання учнів в
умовах іде на світогляд конфронтації які
також отримали гриф мон зараз вчені
працюють над проектом стратегії
залучення ветеранів війни до формування
української ідентичності через систему
національно-патріотичного зокрема
військово-патріотичного виховання на
період до 27-го року 5 сфера освіти
потребує також глибоких психологічних
досліджень особливо в умовах обтяжених
руйнівної війною проти України
вчинена академії опрацьована такі
проблеми
кіберсоціалізація і медіакультурної
грамотності булінгу і посттравматичних
розладів інклюзивного навчання й освіти
осіб з особливим освітніми потребами
психічного відновлення дітей і дорослих
всі наукові установи академії
психологічного профілю напрацювали
відповідні методики рекомендації
щодо дітей і дорослих і створили
необхідні центри групи
проводять заходи це стосується і
науково-методичного забезпечення
психологічної служби системи освіти яке
здійснено центр шосте освіта українські
дітей за кордоном учения академії
долучились до допомоги дітям які
тимчасово виїхали з-за кордону УЗД
здобутті освіти та збереження своєї
національної ідентичності зокрема з
ініціативи вчених академії та за
підтримки Департаменту освіти міста
Варшави в цьому місці Варшаві відкрито
центр дистанційної освіти для
українських школярів завдяки якому вони
мають можливість здобувати освіту за
українськими програмами сьомий
підвищення кваліфікації учителів в
академії створено сучасної оперативну
систему підвищення кваліфікації освітян
це перш за все університет майже до
освіти в цьому році буде підвищено біля
понад 5 тисяч кваліфікацію освітян за
рахунок держави і з інших джерел Близько
трьох з половиною тисяч
Білоцерківський інститут не безперервної
професійної освіти підвищена буде
кваліфікацію двох тисяч осіб за
державним замовленням та порада 2000 за
спеціальним фондом До речі в цьому
інституті створена єдину
освітньо-цифрову екосистему що включає з
сайту віртуальному просторі хмарний
сервіс віртуальна шкоду
онлайн-консультпункт консалтинговий
центр
інформаційно-аналітичні ресурс цифрові
навчальні курси персональні веб-ресурс
викладачів цифрові програмно-методичні
комплекти комплекси YouTube канал тощо
ми вдячні Київській обласній
адміністрації за підтримку цього
інституту який До речі
колишній Донецькій інститут неперервної
освіти який евакуювався В 14-му році в
Київській області
в інституті педагогіки підвищення
кваліфікації здійснюється зарядом
напрямків зокрема вчені які є авторами
модельних навча програми підручників для
п'ятого класу
упродовж минулого навчального року
підготували до роботи понад 21 тисячу
учителів із різних предметів зокрема в
умовах дистанційного світу і я міг би
продовжувати
перераховувати те що ми зробили як скажу
що нам ніколи і наступне 24 лютого
академія прийняла рішення робити все
можливе для того щоб своїми можливостями
своїми зусиллями дати відбір російському
агресору допомогти за країнсь- захистити
українську державність
територіальну цінність і суверенітет Ми
з першого дня війни тісно як ніколи
раніше навіть
співпрацюємо з міністерством освіти і
науки особистого Миколая карликом
відкликаємось на всі заявки і
Міністерства і міністра і його його
заступників і ми надалі будемо робити
все можливе для того щоб підтримати
практичні дає Міністерства комітету
Верховної Ради знову киосвіти всіх вас
шановні колеги і мабуть Останнє що я
скажу ви знаєте За визначенням міністра
диванні експерти часто
ну надзвичайно низько оцінюють
українську освіту оцінювали оцінюють
даючи навіть негативні оцінки на наші
нашим освітянами освітянськими
установами Я думаю що життя ця війна
особливо
поставила
розставила крапки над і аж Подивіться
сотні тисяч людей на треба і мільйони в
тилу захищають Україну Це ті люди які
уже отримали освіту незалежній Україні в
українській школі і захищають вони вміло
вдало я не пам'ятаю в історії Щоб десь
колись якась армія повинна була за
короткий термін оволодіти такою великою
кількістю невідомих невідомий раніше для
них зброї як зробить це українська армія
як роблять це український воїни тому
Слава Україні і Слава українській освіті
Дякую пане Василю кейс педагогічний
наукою для розбудови нової країни Ми
продовжуємо і блок щодо викликів освіти
під час війни в нас завершує зі сторони
поля зі сторони батьків будь ласка
Альона Парфенова співголова громадської
організації батьки SOS
[музика]
Дозвольте всіх привітати надзвичайно
приємно що
попри такі важкі часи голос батьків
чують я вам скажу що з березня місяця
коли я почала від батьків отримувати всю
ситуацію про ці жахи особливо на
окупованих територіях Сергій Миколайович
ви знаєте я до вас зверталась на пряму і
ми просто в оперативному режимі
вирішували ну на мій погляд тоді взагалі
якісь
надзвичайні речі теж саме напевно я
скажу і начальником департаментів місто
областей тому що ви всі знаєте я до вас
зверталась на пряму через Facebook через
там особисті контакти І знаєте це
надзвичайно важливо що ви жодного мого
звернення не залишили поза уваги пане
Василь Я от знаєте ви сказали такі речі
про українську освіту України
доціненність Я хотіла саме з цього
почати давайте згадаємо наші
військкомати
перші тижні це
український випускники українських шкіл
українських вчителів і вони зробили
свідомо свій вибір
ще хотіла б знаєте нагадати вам про
такий вислів школа рідний дім і 24
лютого цей метафоричний вираз він дійсно
став
школа стала просто прихистком для
багатьох українських родин скільки тут
було сплетено і зараз плетуться сіток
скільки смаколиків я знаю що готувалась
на харчоблоках і і відвозилась і в
шпиталі і і передавались скільки взагалі
зусиль і Батьки і вчителі докладають в
тилу для того щоб ми всі вибори нашу
перемогу і насправді зараз мені здається
надзвичайно
серйозним викликом це є окуповані
території там де наші вчителі і вони
дійсно герої я скажу що знаю багато
випадків коли вчителі на окупованих
територіях вони не погоджуються
викладати за російською програмою а по
такі займаються з українськими дітьми
Щоб вони не втратили нашу культуру
знання мови знання історії і мені
здається що це дійсно це героїзм на
сьогоднішній день це так і є і цей який
сьогодні є даосвітан освітяни Незламні
освіта Незламна вона дійсно це Так це
правда і можливо ми самі маємо
переосмислити нашу українську освіту і
попри всі виклики об'єднати всі зусилля
як ми зараз намагаємося на всіх
ланках з Владою об'єднатись так і ми
маємо насправді унікальний шанс от щодо
там квантового стрибку в нашій освіті
Я хочу напевно ще сказати слова
вдячності за те що Ви дали нам
можливість обрати форму навчання для
дітей тому що
щоб в березні ми говорили чи треба
відновлювати освітні процес і дуже
багато лунала таких думок Давайте після
війни я тоді спитала а коли закінчиться
війна ми не знаємо сьогодні
у серпні ми говоримо про те що ми вже
відновлюємо очний процес І знаєте які б
опитування ми зараз не робили але довіру
до влади і до того що ми спільно всі
робимо ми побачимо у вересні ми побачимо
наших дітей у закладах освіти ми
побачимо наших вчителів тому знаєте
закінчити такою фразою поки що накупуємо
контурні карти і виробу в ЗСУ Я вам дуже
всім вдячний
дякуємо
дякуємо дякуємо Пані Альона ми
переходимо до наступного блоку
конференції це інтенсив і також прошу
всіх спікерів трошки пришвид пришвидшити
пришвидшитись Перепрошую так дві дії
одночасно не вийшло зробити ми говоримо
з вами зараз наступний блок повертаємось
до навчання моделі освітнього процесу ми
зараз поспілкуємося з трьох
сторін це Департамент освіти та науки
обласний Львівської ОДА Олег Пасха Так
зараз приготуйтесь вам Зараз будуть
мікрофон також наступний невеличкий кейс
в нас буде це Департамент освіти науки
міської ради Харківської міської ради
пані Ольга і з сторони приватного
навчання так Це зі сторони бізнесу в нас
співзасновник бізнесу асоціації освітніх
закладів банк Костянтин Падалка от будь
ласка Олег якщо можливо нам ваш досвід
щодо моделі освітнього процесу будь
ласка мікрофон прошу
так напевно чути так
Шановний Сергій Миколайович пане голову
комітету Василь Григоровича Шановні
колеги ви знаєте
більше ніж два роки тому ніхто не думав
що буде війна хоча українські політологи
ще в 2002 році про це писали і навіть
формулу закінчення війни вивели але ще
тоді
зважаючи на виклики ковіду була така
спільна ініціатива Міністерства освіти
Національного університету Львівська
політехніка і Департамент освіти і ми
випробовували як в умовах
забезпечити якісне дистанційне навчання
ми відразу тоді почали навчати вчителів
вони освоювали дистанційні платформи і
це було необхідно тому що тоді 95%
вчителів вважати що Viper все віддалене
навчання це була катастрофа станом на
сьогодні в Львівській області з 1
вересня вже 200 шкіл буде працювати на
меті зараз працює 150 приблизно
Це нам що нам Це дало коли почалася
війна в нас було близько 3000 вчителів
які були професійні професійно
підготовлені і вони об'єдналися в такий
світлий волонтерський проект який назвав
всеукраїнська дистанційна школа
і за два тижні за два тижні цей проект
став дійсність
треба було бачити очі цих вчителів
скільки вони всього зробили понад 3000
учнів з Харківської області з
Херсонської запорізької з Донецької з
Луганщини навіть в нас були учні в цій
школі з тих які з Маріуполя вивезли в
Росію
викрали і вивезли
цей унікальний проект дав нам можливість
рухатися дальше він є дуже добрим
досвідом І власне таким
кейсом який дозволить допомогти тим
регіонам і тим дітям які я зараз на
окупованих територіях або в зоні бойових
дій і Львівська політехніка Департаменту
освіти за підтримки Міністерства ми
готові це робити І допомагати але ще
хочу сказати про одну мрію мене мерр
Анатолій і трошки Василь Григорович
сьогодні надихнули згадати про свою мрію
коли я був сільським вчителем в 93-му
році і мене тоді довантажили таким
предметом як історія української
культури які був в рамках
не обов'язково компоненту
і мені
потрапила в руки фантастична книжка
одного з ваших попередників Сергій
Миколайович і ваших попередників Василь
Григоровича Івана Огієнка українська
культура
так от якщо би десь в ті часи ввели
якісь додаткові курс або принаймні
навіть не курс А якби Міністерство
освіти спільно з комітетом Верховної
Ради започаткували добру традицію яка є
в Ірландії Правда в Ірландії дарують
набір книжок тим хто одружується так
парень 20 книжок
в яких є описано це найкращий книжки про
народні традиції про історію культури
Ірландії От якби хоча б одну книжку але
не тоді коли одружується а коли учень чи
учениця завершує 9-й клас
якби Така річ була Я розумію що не зараз
може після війни ми справді станемо
іншою країною бо хто прочитав книжку
українська культура Івана Огієнка той
стає іншою людиною іншим українцям і
хочу подякувати користуючись нагодою
кожному вчителю мій колеги знають що
наші вчителі прибирали варили готували і
вчили дітей і збирали гроші на ЗСУ
Тому низький окрім Слава кожному вчителю
Слава кожному воїну і слава Україні
Дякуємо Олег
Дякуємо і продовжимо будь ласка пані
Ольга Деменко будь ласка проходьте там
де вам зручно
але біля юнісесу мені здається
Дорогі колеги маю честь представляти
місто герой Харків
це
накладає особливо відповідальність Палкі
та щирі слова президента України
Володимира Зеленського Харків ніколи не
буде окупований
це єдине ніколи Це єдине ніколи яке нам
конче потрібно все інше Ми завжди
зможемо
освітяни Харкова не давали клятви
гіппократа не приймали військовий
присяги але залишаються вірними своїй
професії в найскладніших умовах агресії
Мордора проти України проти нашого
майбутнього проти наших дітей
прильоти маємо щодня
наразі пошкоджено
229 будівель вчора ще було 228 це
статистика але як укласти в статистичні
зведення 23 дитячих життя які обірвала
війна
84 тяжко поранених дитини лише за цю ніч
одна дитина загинула і троє тяжко
поранених
харківські вулиці цього не пробачать
А ще Минулого року Харків приймав
нашу Прекрасну всеукраїнську сесію
Україна 30 ви пам'ятаєте і
Сергій шкарлет
озвучив ключові тези менстриму на
розбудову національного освітнього
технопарку чи змусила війна відмовитись
нас нас від поставлених завдань ні
ми адаптували наявну дорожню карту і
створення хабіб з міцний вже вектори що
набули життєво важливого значення
незмінним залишається наше прагнення
зберегти освітній потенціал навчальний
рік рік почнемо першого вересня єдину
можливий варіант онлайн але віримо в
нашу перемогу то ми готуємось і до
очного формату На жаль якщо навіть
дозволить безпекова ситуація то зі 186
шкіл зможемо навчатися лише 100 днів
реберна точка Для нас це укриття попри
військові дії працюємо над їх ремонтами
вже зараз
недавно до мене підійшла жінка з дитиною
і спитала а чи буде кому вчити дітей її
запитання було сповнене на дії на
позитивну відповідь і ми не маємо
жодного права примусити
щоб руйнувань зазнала не тільки будівлі
освіти але й система освіти міста
Харкова зараз більше половини вчителів в
місті не можу не сказати про те що
називають рівними управлінської
відповідальності а простими словами коли
серце болить за справу більше 90%
керівників закладів освіти в місті
підготовкою до навчального року
консолідована вся освітянська спільнота
лежить чверть школярів перебувають в
Харкові але комунікація відбувається
абсолютно з усіма дітьми і знаєте що
надає справжнє крила
80% учнів незалежно від того де вони
знаходяться виявили бажання одержувати
дистанційні знання в харківських школах
4 місяці майже 8 тисяч дітей жили на
станціях метро
так вони подорослішали
але ніхто в них не забере дітей дитячу
допитливість наші педагоги не тільки
проводили уроки вони завжди були рядом
коли страшно І коли сумно
Я дуже вдячна вам Сергію Миколайовичу за
диванних експертів хтось закидав що
дистанційка знизить результативність
наших знань особливо випускників
відповіді на це стали результати
національного мультику предметного
тестування ми В трійці кращих в Україні
[оплески]
тільки за цей навчальний рік 47 перемог
Всеукраїнських інтернет-олімпіад 37
перемог всеукраїнського конкурсу захисту
ман на міжнародних олімпіадах маємо
золото три срібла дві бронзи
Харківське освітянська родина щодня
переконує в тому що неможливо побороти
країну де демонструють сміливість і
свідомість з пелюшок запустили
телеграм-канал харківські герої
освітнього фронту розміщуємо історії
дітей та педагогів які власним прикладом
щодня
доводять незламність нашої нації
запустили челендж діти Харкова прагнуть
Миру учасники розміщують на своїх
сторінках Facebook слова подяки та
підтримки тим хто наближає перемогу На
завершення хочу сказати що важливим є
небажання Перемоги Зараз воно є є у всіх
важливим є воля і готовність до перемоги
ми готові перемагати Миру бути
пані Ольга Дякуємо вам
будь ласка Да я прошу вимкнути мікрофони
щоб не було технічного браку і ми
переходимо
наш блок продовжується модель освітнього
процесу засновник бізнесу асоціації
освітніх закладів Костянтин падунка
співзасновник Перепрошую будь ласка щодо
моделі моделі осіннього процесу зі
сторони приватного бізнесу друзі Вітаю
всіх від імені бізнес асоціації освітніх
закладів ми об'єднуємо на даний час вже
більше 500 приватних шкіл садочків
позашкільних закладів І власне Сьогодні
я висловлюю подяку Міністерство освіти і
науки за те що власне зараз все більше і
більше приділяється уваги приватній
освіті також від мене особлива подяка
департаментам освіти міста Києва та
Київської області спільно з якими лише
за останні роки ми відкрили більше 300
приватних закладів освіти дякую вам і
особливе вітання в місто військових
Харків вже найближчим часом чекайте три
ліцензійні пакети на три нові приватні
школи ми з вами
ми підійшли до того етапу коли приватна
освіта та держава мають стати партнерами
досить довго для приватної освіти
найкращим варіантом було стояти десь в
сторонці І говорити про те що просто Не
чіпайте нас і дайте спокійно працювати
зараз всі ми вся країна на тому етапі
коли цього недостатньо І власне ось це
партнерство вони може стати Вже реально
взаємовигідним проте звичайно дуже
багато викликів Ми сьогодні про це вже
говорили і у приватної освіти вони в
чомусь схожі в чомусь різні їх дуже
багато які основні перше питання - це
фінансування друге питання - це робота
під час воєнного стану і третє питання -
це реалізація державного приватного
партнерства дуже коротко про кожен з цих
напрямів по-перше Робота під час
воєнного стану ні для кого не секрет що
приватні заклади освіти є дуже різними є
садочки на 10 дітей є мережеві школи де
тисячі дітей при цьому вимо для них я
ідентичними і держслужба надзвичайних
ситуацій на даний час не завжди враховує
рекомендації МОН України та власне свої
ж самі рекомендації для того щоб
дозволити приватним закладом освіти
працювати ми з цим боремося постійно
кожного дня і сподіваємось на підтримку
мон в цьому питанні
наступне питання - це фінансування є три
важливі складові перше - це комунальні
платежі з якими дуже важко справлятися з
закладними освіти і ми потребуємо того
щоб нас прирівняли до релігійних заходів
і власне це може бути таким новим
брендом освіта нова релігія Але якщо
говорити Ближче до цифр то нам дійсно
дуже важко переживати кожну зиму
наступне питання кредитування
закладу освіти приватні на даний час
позбавлені пільгового кредитування і
фактично будь-якого кредитування тому що
кожен банк оцінює що приватна освіта це
не є надприбутковим бізнесом і це я так
і ми потребуємо саме пільгових програм
кредитування і останній момент державна
приватне партнерство всі знають
прокуративні заклади освіти які
передбачено на законодавством і для шкіл
і для садочків проте на даний час ми
маємо механізмів реалізації все це
поєднується з тим що є реальні інвестор
є реальні власники закладів освіти
приватних які хочуть вкладати в освіту в
подальшому їм потрібно приміщення або
земельна ділянка або діючий заклад ми до
цього готові власне завершуючи я хочу
сказати про те що
реальним дієвим механізмом для того щоб
всі ці питання реалізовувати може стати
робоча група постійно діюча робоча група
при МОНу України стосовно питань
приватної освіти Ми готові для того щоб
підтримувати один одного і бути
реальними дійсними партнерами Слава
Україні Дякую
Добре Ну що ми рухаємось далі наш
шоколадному засіданні Так ми трошки по
часу Не встигаємо але будемо
прискорюватись ми переходимо до третьому
блоку це співпраця Україна ЄС та інші
країни світу і Починаємо ми з ще одного
вітання і це вітання від міністра
національної освіти та молоді
французької республіки
папи
Я правильно сказав
І в нас формат наступний урок
французької мови давайте швиденько
відпрацюємо на екрані в нас
французька мова Я читаю звершення ви
ваші Оплески добре
шановні Уявіть що він там все шановні
пане міністри Сергію шкарлет я щиро
дякую вам за запрошення взяти участь у
міжнародній конференції яку ви
організовуєте 18 серпня І яка є яскравим
опору та стійкості української
освітянської спільноти в драматичних
обставинах в яких наразі перебуває Ваша
країна на жаль я не зможу взяти участь у
заході про що щиро шкодую але
продовжуючи нашу червневу дискусію Я
хочу поновити своє запевнення в нашій
підтримці вашої країни та наші залучення
у вирішенні нагального питання прийняття
дітей та їхніх сімей які переміщені з
України з 24 лютого весь персонал
Міністерства національної освіти та
молоді повністю мобілізовано на кінець
навчального року на території Франції
навчалися майже 19 тисяч українських
дітей Ми робимо все можливе для того щоб
ці учні знайшли безпечне та комфортне
середовище у французьких школах і
закладах освіти щоб вони зустріли нових
друзів і продовжували своє навчання для
того щоб вони могли стежити за навчанням
та обмінюватись з іншими учнями вони
знаходять посилену підтримку у вивченні
французької мови у світлі перспективи
їхнього повернення в Україну ми подбали
про те щоб учні могли підтримувати
зв'язок зі своєю шкільною системою
українською мовою та культурою З цією
метою майже стовпчителів біженців у
Франції були залучені вони змогли
супроводжувати учнів які хотіли
підтримувати зв'язок із українською
шкільною системою завдяки доступним
цифровим платформам додатково до
червневих курсів 2022 року було
проведено онлайн-заняття з української
мови та культури для бажаючих учнів з
першого по 11-й клас робота цих цих
вчителів також сприяли покращенню
соціалізації учнів також під час
навчальних шкільних канікул в сім'ї та
учнів за бажанням можуть взяти участь у
схемі навчальні канікули яка передбачає
культурну та спортивну діяльність та
дозвілля в межах шкільного закладу
поблизу місця їхнього проживання або під
час перебування в таборах відпочинку
повна мобілізація нашого персоналу
триватиме протягом наступного
навчального який розпочнеться 1 вересня
2022 року прийміть наші запевнення
будьте впевнені п міністра у моїй
рішучості продовжувати задовільняти
потреби учнів в рамках наших можливостей
разом із завіренням в моїй повній
солідарності також висловлюю вам пане
міністр мою найвищу повагу міністр пап
діаїя
і Ми продовжуємо
блок України є співпраця голова
представництва юнісеф в Україні Мурат
Шахін будь ласка вам слово
[оплески]
учасники партнери і я вас завітаю я
нещодавно зустрівся із
банкимуном з попереднім
секретарем ООН і він розповідав згадав
що коли йому було 16 років розпочалася
війна в його країні і його школу було
зруйновано Це було дуже багато років
тому і
це було під час корейської війни
за останні три тижні я відвідав багато
шкіл і я так само побачив зруйновані
школи знов зруйновані школи але я
побачив що працюють вчителі що працюють
у родини
для Анни Миколи для Ніни для Мар'яни
вони
знову мабуть
носіями ідей Миру Вони можливо стануть
представниками в ООН і вони будуть
доносити історію мільйонів українських
дітей ось
зараз такий самий досвід Як колишній
генсекретар ООН отримують діти в Україні
що стосується
університету ми дійсно співпрацюємо з
парламентом змінну освіти з різними
інституціями це було і під час війни і
до війни і буде продовжуватися після
війни тому що освіта - це невід'ємне
право це
наче вода не можна споживати погану воду
бо без води не можна жити так само не
можна жити і без освіти Я знаю що
виклики величезні ми знаємо як
відбувалося
перевезення і ми знаємо що відбулося в
Бучі в Димері в Ірпіні в інших місцях
але звичайно що потреби величезні ми що
можемо зробити можемо триматися разом І
тому спільно до навчання так називається
компанія це не просто
про очне чи заочне навчання це про
спільне навчання про співпрацю і ми
віддані цим цілям чого ми навчилися за
останні час Ми зрозуміли що суто
заочне навчання
неадекватне все ж таки за два роки Кові
до ми побачили що проведення всього
навчального часу за комп'ютером не дає
найкращих результатів тому для дітей
повинні з'являтися
можливості поспілкуватися пограти
укріпити свою соціальні зв'язки
поспілкуватися з вчителями викладачами з
дорослими Тому
нам Важливо не тільки онлайн тільки
офлайн навчання важливе об'єднувати ці
формати і
ми співпрацюємо на постійній основі і з
міністерством освіти над тим щоб кожна
дитина могла реалізувати своє право на
навчання Ми також розуміємо що школа -
це місце де підтримується психічне
здоров'я дитини де відбувається
соціалізація дитини і
ми знаємо що ще три місяці тому в Бучі
дітей з не було зовсім а вже два місяці
тому я побачив що діти повертаються діти
повертаються додому і це перемога
українських дітей сьогодні я бачу що
багато українських шкіл готові приймати
дітей з 1 вересня і ми звичайно віддані
цілям співпраці з вами будемо залишатися
на зв'язку для того щоб розвивати
ініціативу спільно до навчання але це
величезна подорож Вона починається 1
вересня але 1 вересня мабуть стане наче
е-е новорічним святом для кожної родини
і руль батьків в цьому дуже важлива тож
я пропоную щоб з першого вересня до 20
вересня школи були відкриті для кожної
родини я спілкувався з багатьма батьками
і Вони переважно турбуються
через обстріли але вони турбуються через
те щоб вони були могли були бути
близькою до своїх дітей якщо щось
трапляєш вони могли отримати доступ до
своїх дітей негайно Тож давайте залучати
батьків допускати батьків до шкіл
дошкільних приміщень і нехай мандрів
будуть зі своїми дітьми на початку
шкільного року Дякую дякую за ваше
повідомлення так дійсно освіта - це
правильно
повертаюсь до навчання така в нас може
бути історія А ми рухаємось Ви не
уявляєте в Швейцарію і якщо ми можемо
будь ласка в нас на зв'язку
директорка з питань співробітництва
посольства Швейцарії пріске депнерінг
Мої вітання
[музика]
ви нас чуєте зв'язок у нас є так Доброго
ранку Ви мене чуєте так чудово шановні
учасники у
теперішнє складні часи в час війни
освітні заклади мають величезні виклики
як система осити загалом дуже важливо
щоб місцева Влада вчителі освітяни уряд
об’єднали своє зусилля обговорюючи
виклики майбутнього шкільного року і
необхідно намагатися знайти спільні
рішення і в цьому будуть допомагати
також міжнародна спільнота за останні 30
років Швейцарія послідовно підтримувала
реформи освіти в Україні
зокрема за допомогою
підтримки децентралізації в секторі
освіти тому наша довготривала
партнероство як на національному такому
місцевому рівні дозволить надавати і
подальшу підтримку з боку Швейцарії
для
усунення На дивних наслідків
повного-штабної війни
це вражає як за буквально одною ніч
школи перетворилися на притулки на
сховища де надається негайна допомога у
співпраці із мінусом освіти імені
регіону за Польщею
швейцарсько-український проект це
масштабна ініціатива яка зосереджена на
інерації переселенців дітей переселенців
у приймаючи громадах щоб вони відчували
себе так само як і вдома в Україні майже
10 тисяч дітей і сотні вчителів в
багатьох регіонах багатьох областях
України беруть участь в
цій ініціативи яка зосереджується на
базі елітніх таборів і
ми маємо і надалі розвивати ефективне
Партнерство і шукати ефективні рішення
[музика]
існує
можливості оцінювання таке як
багатосциплінарне тестування існує
можливості надавати консультації
щодо того як проводити освіту для
українських дітей приймаючих країнах це
лише деякі приклади нашої спільної
роботи з змін освіти України завдяки цим
заходам ми змогли підтримати дітей
батьків а також вчителів і працівників
системи освіти з перших днів війни
всеукраїнська онлайн-школа
березовий початок з років пандемії і
вона виявилася надзвичайно важливою для
забезпечення сталості освіти мільйонів
дітей також і під час війни наша
посирство активно просувало користу
організації чудово платформою як у
Швейцарії таке в інших європейських
країнах насправді мої друзі вчителі у
Швейцарії надзвичайно вражені програмою
он он яка застосовується в онлайн школі
і вони бажають щоб у нас що зараз теж
з'явився щось подібне і ми прагнемо
запозичити український досвід це хороша
для нас джерело натхнення а от той самий
час
реальність поточної війни шокує
він створює нагальні потреби у ресурсах
тому необхідно продовжувати реформи в
секторі освіти і як підтвердив уряд
України і понад 40 держав і міжнародних
організацій
на
липневій конференції процес відновлення
України повинен чітко зосереджуватися на
реформах це також один із цих ключових
принципів відновлення України плану
відновлення України який також був
прийнятий
і Швейцарія готова підтримувати
ініціативи уряду України котрі
стосується освіти Отож тут ми говоримо і
про впровадження освіти котра
покладається на цифрові інструменти і ці
цифрові інструменти дозволять як учням
так і батькам отримувати якісно безпечно
усі освітні послуги і власне перша леді
Олена Зеленська з ініціювала дуже також
хороші потужні ініціативи і в серці
нашої підтримки залишатиметься
впровадження нової української школи та
реформи пов'язаної з нею на рівні
областей та громад і також сприяння
демократичному урядуванню та відповідних
навичок компетентностей серед як учнів
чи вчителів але також із серед
представників влади і безумовно
відновлення сталий розвиток України і
також євро інтеграція є можливими тільки
через власне розвиток людського
потенціалу і доступ до високоякісної
освіти
є ключем до успіху безумовно Тут також
використовуючи цю можливість я хотіла
побажати усім учасникам та учасницям
конференції чудової комунікації
розбудовує сильних потужних партнер
незважаючи на усі виклики Слава Україні
Щиро дякуємо
і просто і
вітання Вам із України
Будемо продовжувати нашу зустріч
ми дізнаємось проєкт менеджер
швейцарсько-українського проекту Decide
децентралізація для розвитку
демократичної освіти пані Валентина
Полторак ваші Оплески будь ласка Олексій
якщо потрібно будь ласка
Шановні колеги ну пані пріска вже
озвучила дуже багато напрямків нашої
роботи в Україні я би хотіла почати свою
доповідь з статистики дуже вражаючої
статистики сумної статистики на
сьогоднішній день ООН зафіксувала щоб
понад 7 мільйонів громадян України є
внутрішньо переміщеними особами два з
половиною мільйони з них є дітьми дітьми
шкільного віку окрім того понад 5
мільйонів людей сьогодні покинули межі
нашої країни через безпеку ситуацію як
уже зазначали представники місцевої
влади звичайно ми хотіли би щоб всі ці
люди повернулися в Україну це громадяни
українців від яких залежать майбутня
нашої країни і безумовно тим фактором
який сьогодні об'єднує всіх цих громадян
які гуртує їх безумовно цим фактором є
освіта і освітяни тому ми сміливо можемо
казати що освітяни гуртують сьогодні всю
країну і дитина на базі освіти Ми
сьогодні підтримуємо контакти з тими
громадянами України які евакуювалися і
всі сподіваємося на їх повернення і на
їх інтеграцію саме тому проєкт сьогодні
щиро підтримує освіту і освітян з перших
днів війни ми включилися в цю підтримку
і забезпечили ті центри колективного
проживання громадян які знаходились
переважно в школах дитячих садочках
гуманітарної допомоги ми за це
надзвичайно вдячні уряду Швейцарії який
був з нами в контакті майже з перших
годин війни і зробив все можливе для
того щоб це забезпечення доїхало до
Герман доїхала до закладів освіти
окрім того в Цього літа ми проводимо
велику компанію яка називається Де сайт
Саммер clubs ми вдома в Україні цю
компанію започатковано разом з
міністерством освіти і науки з
міністерством регіонального розвитку і
ця компанія залучила понад 30 громад в
16 регіонах України в межах літніх
таборів сьогодні навчаються проводять
дозвілля якісно понад 10 тисяч дітей Ця
компанія спрямована на дітей ВПУ На жаль
їх надзвичайно багато в нашій країні
власне сама назва компанії ми вдома в
Україні означає те що ми хотіли би
визначає наше прагнення щоб кожна дитина
в нашій країні яка сьогодні втратила
свій дім а можливо ще не скоро а туди
повернеться мала таку нагоду відчути
себе вдома в кожному куточку нашої
країни
окрім того проект Де сайт
продовжує свої основні ключові напрямки
проект десант був започаткований
міністерством освіти і мінрегіонам у
20-му році для того щоб
фасилітувати і підтримувати громади
України особливо новостворені громади ми
працюємо з управлінцями освіти по всіх
територіальних громадах України це понад
1407 територіальних громад від початку
війни буквально протягом першого тижня
ми відновили цю роботу у нас працює
група з 50 експертів це юристи
економісти це освітяни які підключилися
до вирішення нагальних проблем відділів
освіти територіальних громад які в перші
дні війни прийняли на себе весь удар
весь організаційний удар війни всі ви
чудово знаєте як управлінці що питання
забезпечення територіальної оборони
питання евакуації громадян все це лягло
на плечі керівників освіти
наш проєкт питання за час війни за ці
перші шість місяців провів 17 вебінарів
консультативних сесій надав понад 500
індивідуальних консультацій кожній
громаді яка до нас зверталася І власне
всі ці матеріали відео все що розроблено
було в рамках цієї компанії На
сьогоднішній день розміщено на сайті
компанія освіта в Нових громадах від А
до Я Ми продовжуємо цю роботу і Я
закликаю всіх управлінців освіти
заходити на наші ресурси звертатися до
експертів ми працюємо для вас ми
працюємо для України Щоб підтримати всіх
управлінців освітою в часи війни
на цьому слайді ви бачите карту
карту тих громад які власне долучаються
до нашої компанії їх кількість
збільшилась під час війни на
сьогоднішній день ми охопили майже всі
територіальні громади України окрім того
ми приділяємо велику увагу цифровізації
в освіті цей пріоритет задекларований
президентом у 2019 році залишається
надзвичайно актуальним в часи війни і
тому разом з міністерством освіти
України разом з беробіон цифрою ми
запустили ініціативу яка називається
управління освіти сьогодні вже зазначали
що нещодавно був проголосований закон
про єдину базу даних айком це власне є
основа цієї компанії саме ця база даних
ця система електронного менеджменту в
освіті дозволить значно скоротити
паперовий документообіг значно скоротить
статистичну звітність і дозволить
оперативно і швидко подавати документи
на які до того управлінець витрачав дні
а може і тижні вже в найближчій
перспективі Ми з колегами з експертної
групи Міністерства освіти інституту
освітньої аналітики працюємо над тим
щоби в доступі для державних органів був
реєстр обліку дітей саме це реєстр над
створенням якого Україна працює
десятиріччями і також удосконалюємо
реєстр обліку педагогічних кадрів окрім
того з 23-го року в межах цієї компанії
буде створений кабінет управління в
якому буде доступний аналітичний модуль
модуль документообігу і також фінансовий
модуль кожен управліннясть буде мати
таку можливість бачити всю свою
статистику починаючи від закладів освіти
від територіальних громад закінчуючи
національним рівнем власне цю компанію
Ми продовжуємо і бачимо в ній велику
перспективу для того щоб скоротити
витрати часу в першу першу чергу
управлінців освітян на виконання
паперової роботи окрім того ми відродили
такий важливий напрям як реформа
шкільного харчування на сьогодні на жаль
ми маємо дуже сумну статистику щодо
проблем зайнятості понад 4,8 мільйонів
людей сьогодні втратили свою роботу
окрім того мільйони евакуйованих
громадян внутрішнього переміщених
громадян Сьогодні мають
не мають можливості забезпечити свої
сім'ї свої родини повноцінним
харчуванням тому ця соціальна складова
вона власне є тією основною причиною з
якою сьогодні з офісом першої леді з
багатьма іншими установами відомствами і
звичайно міністерствами освіти і науки і
відроджуємо цю діяльність Звичайно це не
буде стратегічна діяльність а Це скоріше
буде Знаєте таке певне гасіння пожеж
брати сьогодні надзвичайно важливе
розробити ті механізми організації і
реорганізації шкільного харчування в
громадах для того щоб забезпечити дітей
повноцінним раціоном
в Україні наприкінці Минулого року разом
з юнісеф Україна був відкритий сайт цей
портал знаємо це така абетка абетка
реформи шкільного харчування це є портал
продовжує свою роботу там розміщені
відео всі аналітичні матеріали які
допоможуть і управлінцями учителям
організувати харчування правильно
виходячи з тих умов які є у нас на
сьогоднішній день
окрім того звичайно реорганізація
шкільного харчування в першу чергу буде
вмотивована тим що логістичні шляхи на
сьогоднішній день зруйновані зруйновані
порушення мережі закладів освіти
зруйновані системи Скажімо так і
знесилений ринок постачальників послуг
але на сьогоднішній день є готовність
всіх органів влади подолати цю проблему
вирішити її напрацювати ефективні
механізми з органами місцевого
самоврядування з відділами освіти громад
які дозволять забезпечити всі пільгові
категорії категорії дітей які цього
потребують повноцінним харчуванням
найближчим часом Коли у нас буде повна
статистика щодо тих закладів освіти які
повертаються до повноцінної флайнової
роботи ми запропонуємо серію вебінарів
консультативних сесій серії аналітичних
документів які опублікуємо разом з
міністерством освіти і науки
колеги ну регламент сьогодні надзвичайно
короткий хочеться розказати дуже багато
але в цілому скажу що проєкт Який
Швейцарія підтримує розвиток освіти
підтримує освітян тому що вони сьогодні
дійсно це другий фронт України ми з вами
і всім нам звичайно бажаємо Перемоги
миру і як найскоріше повернення до
повноцінного освітнього процесу Дякую
колеги дякуємо дякуємо пані Валентина
продовжуємо блок співпраці Україна ЄС в
нас ще два кейси будь ласка заступник
мера Варшави рината козновська онлайн з
нами Зараз чекаємо підключення і
так є
відео відео так будь ласка відео
»
.»
[музика]
показуючи сузір'я під час Цей брутальний
воїни на пасці Русі на ваш Край ми як у
Варшава рубіном 6 аби натурена Ілля
[музика]
істоможливектора що вони в тих пірших
днях іти до Дня воїни керування
до України чудові до Києва Львова ніж
Харкова але наша праця один ваші рудні ж
то на месте щас до польськи бігало понад
5 мільйонів уход з України він вигравав
отара і до Європи
Мені дуже вручили теж з поворотом до
своєї до краю в Варшаві до целово
зачинаву ще А кого сущий там де ще
нічого вступ очень дешеву Тищенко
з України а помолці
каже сам час воїна тоді з того четверте
голову понад де він чувства
з України это самое тута і у нас
заставили
помадами з народженням праці з
народженням мешкає чи те ж спрос
запевняє мешкання на
гістоможливе але нашимберзу дуже
визванням є зручніше дукація
не служилишими дива система адвокат сина
актора функціонує і мами надіє жите два
системи функціонал
в тоїсти наш польський систем адвокат
цей не а він це наука стаціонарна або
польські підстави
понад щоден нащо і бути що вам це учнів
з України участь ще в наших школах з
старого підприємств
в школі А ви нові у цю сіль в наших
шкалах Спожив річний барзові але так
званих
[музика]
діало і в школах підставових і в школах
понад підставив ставових суто об'яви где
моді шедевши з ким учиш я і язика
польський дом і стаціонарніших гаджетів
інтегрова Але у чому ще рух ніж щодня то
впастибувних під м'яту партію ж а
польські підстави англійська мова Діти
хто вже хозом чи готова вчитель шанса по
зостала молодіж ходіть до школи обувних
зачинає цим
адвокаціями в польських школах з
рувішніками з Варшави і так діючий
чи Тищенко тепер це дуже вызвание для
дівчинки з України але тут теж обжимієве
звання для нас аби способ Як найлегше
так адвокатці завдання
екзамен в мене багато віру партнеру в ту
же нам помоглі гідним значенням інших
партнерів
нам фінансування
в дидактичний
Отож для нас і помог нам з організовать
дату в місті Варшава у два рази в юруля
для мешканців нашого міста для учнів
учениць організує харіжі і організує в
акація
та ізбардзо інтересом
адвокації в місті для швидких тих хто
вже не могу вам виїхати або виїжджаємо
на Барт закрутка чим краще вакацийним
запевнями
бардзо бардзо дуже ружник фракції вища
до кінь до театру до Варшавський дозор
до центру науки Копернік вчитель ж
просто заяча заняття спортове в наших
об'єктах спортових вона заяча школа
нечеружна музичне Театральна кукатих
зайнятість зовєра встиг заяють каже
учнів із України вона додавати що вам це
учнів записало ще на лятовміщення
оплат турець тому що я вам покрити
заставу часи юніцеф тури так як повітрям
із для нас знаками партнерам А ми каже
теж други Барт уважного партнерством
помо це німці народова і польський
центром повноцемінниці народова і Туре
вивожу короткий фінансово вона
затруднені понад 200
губні научиться війна учить через з
України дуже самому асистентами в наших
шкалах і помагає йому е порским
варшавським научителем і научиться роком
ось чим з України в спаньованому це
іспаніював співпраця то ні було би
можливо без польських центром це мінзи
народовий нами теж приватних дарчий
партнеру хто ж десерт Чилі компутери до
серця гілля птахи виправ кішка з
портовом для дітей з України для учнів з
Україною жінки тема та системи вода а є
ще більш певно і спойлена мама теж з
партії психології чи на ні звикли
подшебна із партії педагогічна
учняв і плутай знов і мені це є
бенефіціантом
фінансової партнером
то в Спарті психологічного педагогічна з
організованість і тоїсть наука
в партію опорцію підстави програмове
наука в наших школах містиш другій
систем которая збудова річ майна актори
поставив Їй більше на акторівні звикла і
став Вона екзюбарду у вас навіть рух між
пані сферола ам’яновича Ісла наука
здавна партію о український
[музика]
учнів вікушка по заставав українським
системі адвокаційним як у Варшава
помагами і всі
системи гучність данною пані ваша мама
що я дамо що наших
зйомзани хоча ж без інфраструктурного
школи ну є межами в стані п Шиян з
додаткових
учнів з України в нашій школі
то ви означало вже в цьому досувні пару
міщанці в Варшаві повинно повстать
корейних 400 школа на той шанс учнів
кажда і вспоминает очевища
научителяхті тут і мами браки і буряками
ще з браками чичері для нас зваженість
або консистем едукації з даний рух ніж
розвіять і пишіть ідея і знов нашим
знаком і тим партнерам yestern unicef
разом з іншим збудували дуже центром
комунікації і розвиваю місто таке місце
где мочиш може пшищ і учаться
за шкалами упаінства
для прикарпатської нам це ж так база
подшерні ми Варшаві товаришіми систем
сон стану війська тільки мій сумує 102
дівчат ляпток бувши готувати
в Україні і учить так їх центру збудувач
між кілька а до [ __ ] це ми їх збудувати
в Варшаві кількадішнів і довше сказати
так аби до її ще ні В каждый нашої
дільниці Так є центром адвокації
повставо розміщенням О учнях дуже не маю
вдома 2 роки до науки з даний запрошами
і того так їх місця учнів дуже
позовстанням з українським системі
адвокат сейнем у нас бендамоглі о
прочитай його участь чи нзк морськийга
брать удя
експертів психологічного педагогічного
дарсонажа аби молодіж не залежить От так
отче учить ще Ну по-перше
українські підстави і програмової
системи з даним аби була за опікувана В
каждом своїх обшару Робіна в шістка аби
як знаєте за опікаваті дітей і емоцій з
України і ми ще Вже нам ще то удая то
вільків віршів як і праця мої співпраця
в нікул уже іншим м'яса в наших
пощамунних дільницях і директору в нашій
школі образ моді вже директором моджі
Барви завшитінкує зато як базуб шияшні і
звірком отвар тощо серце чиєрі може то
Варшавський школу і Стараємося помагач
знаєте як потрахеом родичам веляпшия ж
ні е-е Мінському польському що
українські ноукраїнська Отже ж очищає
польський чи що это важно час і мама
значить спожиткує mego як знайти Я бачу
що нам цю якийсь за вчинившись він
закінчення війни якнайшебша а паньство
вже чи як нас- найспокойніша року школа
Дякуємо пані Рената і далі співпраця
України ЄС і інші країни світу за інші
країни світу в нас відповідає пан Джон
Лайнс президент компанії
seventy
Seven to Zero Global Hero High
[музика]
Я перепрошу те що в мене таке
невизначене тло я вітаю усіх вас В мене
є кілька слайдів які я хотів би вам
продемонструватись що в мене нова такої
технічної можливості Я коротко розкажу
хто ми такі і розкажу який продукт
становить основну нашого уроку Наша
компанія глобального характеру ми
працюємо в сфері інновацій і глобальних
партнерство ми роками Працюємо з такими
як кока-кола волмед Дісней в наших
команда
дійсно міжнародна і ми працюємо заради
завтрашнього дня ми працюємо на те
питаннями які пов'язані в тому числі і
сільським господарством і ланцюгами
поставок А ми намагаємося знайти нові за
системи
Ми також навчаємо кампанію в тому числі
українські компанії українських фермерів
Ми також
розуміємо що зараз
необхідно
знаходити додаткові ресурси для
підтримки України і ви сьогодні побачите
один продукт який було створено за
допомогою наших зусиль і це таке
брендовий проект брендовий продукт
це
такий напій який має високу поживну
цінність при цьому
невисоку вартість
ми працюємо над розширенням нашої
програми ми залучаємо додаткові ресурси
від наших партнерів ми
просуваємо
smart-технології на розвиток
високопоживних
продуктів таких як наприклад
спеціальні супи або енергетичні напої
технології приходять на допомогу на вони
відкриті ними можна користуватися і на
початку нашого партнерства з компаніями
у Штатах вони
висловили своє бажання надати підтримку
в тому числі і учня і
наша спільнота постійно розширює це
зібрати якомога більше ресурсів зібрати
комусь більше партнерів всі ми прагнемо
допомогти Україні і ми маємо
честь підтримувати вас всім Чим можемо і
слава Україні
ось тут на місці де було підписано
меморандум ви пам'ятаєте воно
продовжується і тут буде або завершенню
вже пленарного засідання і по-перше хочу
подякувати тому що говорити складно а
навик слухати ще тяжче тому що аудиторії
Оплески самі собі ви надзвичайні ми тут
спілкувалися що ви не тримаєтесь але
Дякуємо вам так і ми чекаємо на
готовність готову Так є бонус Як ви
знаєте Чеська Республіка головою нині в
радійс і пан Міністр освіти молоді та
спорту Чеської республіки
готовий
з нами так так готовий вийти з Владимир
Балаш так будь ласка
[музика]
Шановні колеги пані та панове перш за
все Вітаю вас із тим що ви змогли
організувати цю конференцію за поточних
обставин як
головуюча країнами вже організували
кілька подій і
я розумію Наскільки важко проводити
організацію таких заходів я розумію
наскільки вам було складно і я дійсно
маю честь виступити сьогодні перед вами
російська агресія проти України це
та подія Яку не можна пробачити і забути
і ті страждання той білі який ви зазнали
не мали би статися в Європі 21 століття
і це загроза для майбутнього Європи в
тому числі і багато дітей учнів вчителів
втратили можливості вчитися і працювати
Вони стоя перед величезним викликом
біженці які проживають чеські Республіці
І врешті країни Європейського Союзу теж
стикаються
доступом до освіти але участь і
Республіці існують унікальні можливості
для українських біженців ми проводимо
інтеграцію не платити за семінацію і ми
вітаємо українських біженців українських
дітей і спонукаємо їх підтримати зв'язки
з українською культурою не ми негайно
прийняли два законодавчих пакети і
завдяки цьому школи мають можливість
пристосовувати
освітній сім'ї до потреб учнів з України
не залежно від для того як виглядає
національна програма Таким чином кожна
Школа може підвищити кількість
класі де навчався іншими мовами і
більш того
діти з України
вчителі з України можуть також
залучатися до
допомоги до роботи асистентами
освітнього процесу навіть якщо у них
немає
закінченої педагогічною освітою І я
хотів би згадати також національний план
відновлення який забезпечує незалежне
фінансування в рамках відновлення
підвищення стійкості
і зараз у нас відбувається активне
фінансування
на
22-23-й рік приділяється 40 мільйонів
євро і в 20-му році на це біля 20 до 30
мільйонів вже в Європейському Союзі було
вжито багато заходів для того щоб
підтримати Україну у сфері освіти і
наприклад з
програми підтримується мобільність
здобувачів освіти з України кожен На
українській здобував чи може взяти
участь у цьому проектах мобільності
університетів співробітник може також
запросити зараз грант для того щоб взяти
участь у навчання навіть Незважаючи на
це обмеження можливості
головування Чеської Республіки в Раді
Європейського Союзу теж
відкриває багато можливостей для
співпраці між Україною і ЄС наші колеги
з українських міністерств часто стають
важливими гостями на наших заходах радо
приймаємо у українських делегації на
різних заходах під час нашого
голосування це конференція нас ЄС де
працювала високорівнева група присвячена
освіта і навчання
українські делегації вже
беруть участь у дискусіях на рівні ЄС
щодо потреб української системи освіти
наприклад завдяки співпраці на
Європейському рівні на рівні
Європейської комісії Ми швидко
рухаємося уперед у сфері забезпечення
українських учнів підручниками і
звичайно що все змінилося внаслідок
російської агресії і в сфері освіти
важливо підтримувати не тільки цифрову
освіту є ще один важливий елемент Це так
зване цифровий добробут учня їхня оксида
має бути безпечною ефективною і за
можливістю мотивованою ще одним аспектом
є допомога із підтриманням психічного
здоров'я на належному рівні за рахунок
необхідної консультації
ми розуміємо які виклики існують сфері
освіти і науки через
повномасштабне вторгнення Російської
федерації на території України Я думаю
що забезпечення добробуту - це один з
таких викликів і я не можу сказати що це
щось надмірне має бути фізичний
психічний добробут учнів це необхідно
для хороших результатів навчання це те
чого Всі ми маємо прагнути впродовж
наступних років школи повинні знову
стати безпечним місцем І наступного
тижня я особисто відвідую Україну для
зустрічі з моєму українським колегою
паном шкарлетом І також я відвідую деякі
школи і у нас буде можливість укріпити
наші зв'язки і підтвердити готовність
співпрацювати і підтримувати Україну на
національному рівні на рівні ЄС Я вважаю
вам плідно і кон пенсії присвячений
освіті і майбутньому вашої країни
дякую вам
[оплески]
дякуємо дякуємо Ну що на цьому наші
пленарне засідання майже не турбуйтесь Я
хочу люди що Я ж бачу настрій аудиторії
про що ми хочу подякувати Давайте ми
подякуємо всім спікерам вони також весь
час були з нами більше з них в нас
конференція продовжується 12 локацій про
що
Сергій Миколайович казав правильно в нас
є відео про ці локації зараз невеличке
декілька
[музика]
[оплески]
а-а-а-а-а
[музика]
[оплески]
-ай
так і нагадую про хештег повертаюся до
навчання обов'язково будь ласка
використовуйте його і сьогодні під час
від нього локації коли ми тут всі
спільно разом зі мною якщо в нас є
нагадування про хештеги якщо воно
потрібно на відео воно також з'явиться
пан Сергій можливо зробити
[музика]
так і можливо декілька слів як саме по
завершенню будь ласка
які реалізовані компанії
але тоді в нас був мир
на сьогодні Мені дуже приємно Джон
лейнссон не просто під'єднувався до нас
це великий бізнесмен великі патріот той
американець який безмежно підтримує
Україну і чому саме він
так сталося ми познайомились він він
дуже активно робить багато данації
Україну І це не просто філантроп
бізнесмен він ще великий інноватор і
саме можливо його винахід
дасть нам спроможність відновити хоча би
частинку того шкільного харчування яке
яке повноцінно запроваджувалося але тоді
коли був мир
нас сьогодні є певна атракція Я думаю що
ми з паном Сергієм спробуємо запросим
пані Альону батьків Микола анатольчика
давайте якось атракці спробуємо це є
винахід там є сухі йогурт є сухі
бульйончик це можна зробити
водичку і спробувати чи піде воно як
такий малесенький Снек малесенька
канапочка чи може бути малесенький
якийсь презентація наш друг колега
товариша освітянин доктор наук пан
максимовиччук Можливо трошки більше про
це скаже
Шановні колеги Шановні учасники форуму
шановний Василь Григоровича
ви знаєте так дійсно я пишаюсь тим що я
сьогодні долучився до роботи цього
освітянського форуму який є
всеукраїнський який наразі дуже вчасно і
дуже потрібний
дякуючи Міністерство освіти і науки
безпосередньо Сергій Миколайовичу як
його очільнику і його бравій команді ми
запропонували разом з американськими
іспанськими колегами
[музика]
наших дітям в такій непрості часи ми
розуміємо яка кількість дітей є
внутрішньо переміщеними яка кількість
дітей і яке навантаження на школи на
харчові блоки на їдальні зараз і при
тому всьому ми не забуваємо про те що
наша перша леді України пані Олена
Зеленська є
векторним рушієм цієї системи щодо
покращення харчування наших діточок
особливо в аспекті здорового харчування
ми пропонуємо цей продукт як молочний
біфідойогурт
повністю екологічного стандарту без
всіляких сторонніх домішок це ти продукт
який на відміну від звичайних йогуртів
не вимагає
інкубування там протягом там 5-6 годин а
є миттєвого
приготування на прикладі простої води чи
молока сирого молока в тому числі і
молока яке є із холодильнику
технологія
повністю сертифікована американською
системою fda Тобто вона є
доречною до того щоби використовуватись
в будь-яких закладах Тим паче навчальних
ми разом із заступником міністра освіти
віри борисівної роговою відпрацювали і
подали міністром пропозиції щодо 4
пілотних областей України в яких ми
випробуємо ці технології як гуманітарна
місія уже готова велика партія цих
йогуртів Я думаю що після підписання
меморандуму ми пришвидшимо цей шлях до
того щоби Наші діти не страждали а були
здоровими і утворювали чудову українську
націю і народжувала нам здорових і щирих
діточок Сергій Миколайович якщо ви
анонсували ми можемо просто
при всіх
продемонструвати цю цю ідею життя От і
будемо просити
благословіння на те щоб як скоріше ці
технології бачили бачили впровадження в
нашому житті Всі ми знаємо що таке
їдальня що таке
учні які завжди десь
спішать Є певні проблеми з часом а це є
миттєво А можна всім з Бразилії щоб не
було в нас конфліктів все ж таки
підходьте будь ласка раз такий формат
Так пані та панове
особисто перевірка
ну Ми дякуємо Ми дякуємо
всім гостям і за декілька хвилин
[музика]
будь ласка
Якщо хтось хоче поближче подивитись ми
не проти підходьте до Я розумію і хочу
від себе особисто і від всіх подякувати
кожному за вашу увагу подякувати
спікерам подякувати команді технічній
міграційній подякувати
шановні з молоком просто оскільки
потрібно робити
місто Буча за е-е прийом та організацію
всім Дякую а-а Слава ЗСУ все буде
Україна